what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
all right before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in um let's get
started I'm a couple quick announcements
before we start the show the first guy
is subscribe to our Clips channels just
for eclipse and pearl daily second thing
uh make sure you if you want to be a
part of the chat today make sure you
sign up for our first membership tier uh
King how many likes
1500 a thousand five hundred likes to
open up the chat today and super chats
are going towards getting King a camera
so if you guys want to see what king
looks like you know donate for a king
camera
um okay guys um welcome to the show um
why don't we start everyone say your
name your age and today because we are
doing a pro-life versus pro-choice panel
um say if you're pro-life or you're
pro-choice to start the show starting
here go around and then we'll do second
row
hi I'm Milan I'm 27 and I'm pro-choice
okay hi I'm Claire I'm 31 and I'm
pro-choice
hello everyone my name is Yen Ting
I'm forever 25.
um what does that mean forever are you
25 are you not 25. I'm just forever 25.
so so older than 25 yeah okay okay
I don't have to say my age you mean
you're supposed to yeah um so basically
I'm pro-choice okay pro-choice go ahead
hi uh I'm Aurora I am 29 unfortunately
um and I'm pro-choice
okay go ahead hi I'm Callum I'm sadly 31
I'm a millennial and again even sadder
I'm pro-life so probably not very
popular but I'd love to have a good
conversation okay go ahead I'm Lois I'm
27 and I am happily pro-life for both
moms and babies okay go ahead what about
you I'm Danielle I'm 23 and I'm
pro-choice
hi I'm Lauren I'm 31 and I am in the
middle
okay so what does that mean are you like
Pro Choice after a certain point I think
um there's many many reasons I'm I think
it all depends I think it
depends on the situation okay but if you
had to pick one legal or not legal I
could not
I I could not okay sorry I ever I'm like
just bang in the middle I'm
it
what can I say I don't know okay I'm in
the middle okay all right that's all
right go ahead
hello everyone I'm TR Michelle back
again here pleasure to be back and I'm
uh I've already said my age I'm not
about to say again but I'm pro-choice
okay go ahead hello I am also back again
it's nice to be back
um my name is Kelly and I am pro-choice
and I'm I just want to clear out
something out really fast I am not
transgender
okay I I don't know what our editor was
doing I don't know he was on something
I'm gonna I'm gonna yeah are bad I look
at it they post so many Clips
I was like I don't know
um okay so my first question do you guys
know somebody that's had an abortion
yes um so starting here go around and
then second row and then what was their
experience like or your experience if
you want to share it go ahead
um yeah I have
I definitely have and
um
from the outside looking in it doesn't
look very it's obviously it's an
emotional it's an emotional thing to go
through I wouldn't
wish that situation in a hole on anybody
because it is and it must be a tough
decision very tough decision to make
it's sad to watch people go through
stuff like that so did you say you had
one yourself I've seen you've seen one
so what was the reason they had one
um
probably just like to be fair I don't
live their life so I don't really know
what they was really going through to be
fake people only choose to tell you what
they want you to know so from what I do
know
um
I don't think it was the right time for
them or something like that okay a great
time okay go ahead
yeah same here I've I've seen quite a
few of my friends going through it
and I feel like as soon as you stop
speaking about it that's when you start
realizing there's actually more women
than you think that actually go through
it each year is actually crazy and
um it's something that it's actually
hard to pick a side actually for me I
was like pro-life pro-choice is
something that I understand both parts
and I feel like it's just depending on
the person their situation there's a lot
of things to take in account
so it's actually a tough decision and
it's something really hard to go through
definitely okay what was the reason they
had one
some people don't mention the reasons I
think it's something very like intimate
to each one like so that friend didn't
didn't tell you what no I had one not
necessarily yeah but most the time it's
because it's bad timing wrong person
personal I know like Financial issue
this type of things definitely okay bad
timing in person go ahead
um I'm pretty agree with you Cleo for me
I would say the most earliest abortion
news was from one of my friends
and it was in high school obviously it
was too early for her too you know to
have the baby and she had to do the
abortion and that's one of the reason I
support
I mean kind of in the middle but if I
have to use one I go for a pro-choice
but luckily her boyfriend that time
would stay with her all the all the
process so it wasn't too bad so he was
he was like support did he want it to
um I think both of both of them um
didn't want didn't want the baby okay it
was too early okay got him
so yeah uh once
and I actually understand her very much
because
um
she had been like a fantastic mother to
two other children
and so she already had two she had two
children
um and she had sort of sacrificed her
education and sort of moving forward in
life and then she met this guy who just
knew that like we are perfect for each
other but she was very uncertain
and then
um she became pregnant after a month but
then like she had two other children and
she wanted to and the two other kids
were sorry I'm just they were not here
okay yeah okay but she was like and then
she chose to take care of the children
that she had instead of bringing in like
another child I actually think it was
twin so it would have been like two
other people
um and she told me kind of like a little
bit shameful and I think she felt very
relieved when I said like oh I
understand you and I don't think she had
gotten that reaction from other people
before yeah okay
um so what was her reasoning just like
she didn't want two different dads or
she didn't think she could take care of
the kid money money yeah yeah I mean
they were living in like a basement flat
and she was sort of
her entire life revealed around
um her two children like she couldn't
afford bringing in two other third yeah
like for having four children and and
then I mean she didn't want to you know
risk having another dad leaving again
you know okay yeah what about you yeah I
know loads I think I mean one in three
women in our country has an abortion in
their lifetime so all of us know tons
and it's way more common than people
realize so yeah I know people who have
had an abortion who thought it was the
right decision I know people who have
had an abortion and then ended up being
pro-life activist I know people that
have done abortions you know as doctors
or whatever so yeah it's extremely
common and everyone reacts in different
ways as we've seen already
yeah like comes at so many to
specifically come to mind I guess one
who was at 19 one who was 35 uh so 19
year old uh girl really heartbreaking uh
story in that she ended up doing
performing her own abortion at home
through the pills by post scheme that's
now available in the UK that abortion
providers can just send at pills by post
and she did true oh really they send you
abortion by mail here exactly wow so
this started in the pandemic and it's
now continued on past the pandemic so
she had a really terrible experience and
now um she's actually yeah has joined a
more pro-life stance and another 35 was
was more similar in that she she already
had kids and she was looking to take a
step up in her career so that was more
she was more of a stable situation but
but made that choice
okay go ahead
um I don't know anyone personally but
then sometimes I actually think maybe I
do know someone that's had it but
they haven't been vocal about it because
obviously I mean there is still the
stigma with abortion which I personally
think there shouldn't be I think it
should be
what you do with your body is your
choice really I think there should be
more stigma really yes so we're we're
completely different yeah very different
we should have the most stigma yeah okay
so very interesting so completely yeah I
think I think we should stigmatize it
more okay interesting yes but it's okay
keep going keep going so yeah so I don't
I don't personally know anyone
um but again maybe there is someone that
I know that's close to me that I just I
just didn't tell you yeah exactly I I'm
I'm not sure but yeah but so as far as
you know as far as I'm concerned no but
but it could have it could have happened
yeah one out of three is a big it's yeah
it's exactly okay go ahead
um I know quite a few people that have
had abortions
um I've got friends that have had
abortions and then regretted it
um which is awful to see
um
and I've had friends that are completely
against it
and
um
part of them and I can see that part of
them
want to be
they they wanted to get an abortion
because they I've been in a in what I
meant by I'm in the middle is there's so
many it just all depends there's so many
situations like
um one of my friends in particular
um
she's in an extremely toxic situation
didn't have the means didn't have you
know the
work there was no uh stability there is
no
um
thought so she was in like a toxic
relationship extremely toxic
relationship but not just a relationship
a whole like the life a lifestyle
everything
um and what I'd like what's worse
bringing a baby into an extremely
knowing that it's extremely toxic
situation
um
and this child not being able to live
and be a child and or um spend their
life
um affected mentally emotionally and
then they have to spend the rest of
their life struggling through therapy
and
um
trying to heal off after all this mess
and and then she she feels guilty about
it right
um or to
get an abortion I would say the second
and yes the second so I I this is why I
really do think it depends and I think
it's every situation is different I
think ones especially that is going to
it's like it's it's apparently it's
supposed to be about saving
um like pro-life saving the trail but
pro-choice could also save a child from
a lifetime I just but the way I think
about it like I think it'd make more
sense to tell women don't date toxic Men
and don't put yourself in that situation
you said or you didn't but it's like why
are you in that situation to begin with
you know what I mean yeah well I agree
but there's um there was also one of the
people that I know that got an abortion
was a drug addict
and she was
and when I say drug addict I mean
full-on
heroine and all of that and she knew she
couldn't stop it she knew she wanted to
stop it but she got pregnant and she
wanted to keep the baby and what what I
don't you know there's people like that
that um
I agree with but then I also hear
stories but then I'd say get off of
drugs oh I'd say get off with drugs I'd
say stop dating in that waste man but
it's it's like we agree yeah we're on
the same this is why I'm like
I don't have a no and a yes it's it's
all depends okay it all depends okay
what about you
I feel like I do know uh women that have
had an abortion however they haven't
told me as they're going through it I
think it's something that they probably
only maybe share with
you know people that are really close to
their more
you know maybe other women or something
but
um I've had people tell me like you know
that they've had it's happened to them
in the past they've made that decision
you know in the past
um however I suppose the reasons have
been already mentioned today you know it
could be because they're young
it could be because
they're not with the right person you
know they might not feel like they're
gonna get adequate financial support
what do you think about it who's the
right person someone that's going to
support you well I would think like most
people like yeah I mean you'll be
surprised if half of us are getting
divorced anyway it's like most people
are with the wrong person anyway but you
know what I hear you however like some
people the relationship doesn't work out
however they still do their best for
their child but some people they don't
care in the beginning with they never
cared and those are the people shouldn't
be having kids yeah well I just think
that's like the woman's fault yeah
because why'd you pick him you know what
I mean the thing is yeah I agree with
you I agree with you I agree with you
100 like it's the women however
sometimes men present themselves in a
certain way and it's a facade well I
think then you should you know so some
women they they get tricked well I think
maybe we should probably you know then
take longer to like sleep
100 do you do you think really
taken down no no no no they say 50 wait
a whole I found a new staff 50 of women
do not wear a condom with a new partner
it's crazy that's crazy because it's not
just a baby you can get diseases from
that as well that's just crazy 50 it's
actually 53 if we're gonna go a little
yeah anyways go on what about you it's
also gross on the men's part I'm gonna
be honest um so we're on the women
though I would put it way more on the
women yeah it's both gross um so yeah I
I do have a story and I hope that this
will endear me to the pro-lifus a little
bit because it's a personal story not me
but my mum had an abortion
and
um she had announced the pregnancy to
all of her kids she was intending on
keeping it
however
um this was a while back and I was a kid
as well we didn't have access or good
access to the internet or at least my
mom didn't know how to use it too good
so my mom had all of her kids in her 30s
but by this point she was now 40 and she
had been I guess scared that by the
increasing statistical chance of down
syndrome
now my mom's friend had a kid with Down
Syndrome so she went to see her friend
she spoke to her about it a bunch and in
the end she decided that if that was
going to be the end result that she
couldn't manage
she did have four kids already
um but if she had been able to know or
someone had actually told her that the
statistical likelihood of having a child
with Down Syndrome
was incredibly low just because it's
increased she'd had a healthy kid two
years before
I think she would have kept
the kid because we were she wouldn't
have announced it to all of her children
otherwise so I do think and I I was
excited I only have brothers so I was
like heck yeah this will be my sister
finally I was like to my mom
can I name it if it's a girl this so it
wasn't a happy situation it wasn't done
lightly and I do think it was done
um
sadly considering that it was based out
of being scared and not having that
information that she might have made a
different decision otherwise do you
think the doctors pushed her to do it no
they didn't push her but by providing
the statistics were saying there's an
increased chance it's not telling you
how still how small that is especially
if you've just had a child two years
prior and all of your children have been
healthy it's just what'd your dad think
about it
um so this was not my dad um I have one
brother and then I have two half
Brothers
um I think they were both sad about it
it wasn't it wasn't
um yeah it wasn't a decision that was
taken lightly
yeah so this is why I think abortion
should be banned I would ban it no
exceptions well I'm definitely not okay
with the lack of information and I do
think that sometimes
people get scared because they're like
oh if you haven't had a kid by 35 then
it's a geriatric pregnancy
um but we should be evaluating these
things on a case-by-case basis fertility
is a whole other thing and it's you know
you shouldn't be scaring people out of
what might be otherwise healthy
pregnancies if they actually want to
keep them because the majority of
abortions are had by women that already
have children
60 percent
wow you think they'd keep them then they
already did the first to my mom's case
yeah it was not talking about your mom
I'm just talking yeah I think usually
when it's mothers that are having
abortions it may be because they they
think they can't cope I think it's less
money and it's more coping if you've got
two or three or in my case my mom's case
four kids and then she's thinking it
might be disabled as well you start to
think oh I can't cope I'm gonna like die
from stress like I'm gonna fall apart
um obviously that's not necessarily the
case
um and it can come from you know not
feeling like you have enough support one
way or the other
[Music]
um
but I think it usually comes from being
scared in some way
yeah but I just think we have like a
better quality of living than we've had
in all of human history generally
speaking but I think after a certain
point you don't get any additional like
child tax credits and benefits Beyond is
it the third child
yeah but then like my answers get
married stay married yeah
um well
that that that's dependent on whether or
your husband is successful at taking
care of you and to be fair on men you
might be able to happily support two
kids but four five six just might be out
of your budget right and I know that's a
tough thing to say but I don't think
money should be a predominant factor in
deciding this but it is a factor for
some people so I'm curious pro-choicers
when I'm assuming you guys think life
begins at conception yeah okay
um pro-choicers when do you guys think
Life Begins how many weeks month what is
it what do you guys think should
abortion be legal up to birth three
weeks a month like what's your starting
here and then
go ahead got in sorry yeah when should
abortion be legalized
um well to be fair
the laws at the moment isn't it like 12
weeks or something 24.
it's six months six months okay I don't
agree with that but I'm sure that at
some point was it 12 weeks I don't know
where I got that from but I'm sure
that's on 12 probably 12 weeks yeah it's
not 12 weeks is is what you can get the
pill up to is it the pill and then after
that you can get the pill for longer
beyond that all right
but it becomes more likely that you'll
get a surgical the later on that you're
getting it yeah yeah well they're
literally taking the mick with it right
now they've
um they're talking about putting it up
to like two months off or a month off
there was there was that's too much
that's
murder to me yeah that's too much yeah I
wasn't aware of that because I don't
know the stats some children have
survived at less than six months at like
five and a half yeah
up to three months and then after that
if you don't want it just give it to
adoption there's lots of people that
can't have kids after that just give
birth give it to us yeah I mean at six
months you're almost all the way there
you know what I mean when you're 12
weeks isn't that when you have like your
first scan like when I had my son I have
a nine-year-old so when I had my son you
have your first gun when you're 12 weeks
and then you have another one when
you're 25 weeks and that's when you find
out the sex
um I would say in my world
depending on people's circumstances
everyone's different but when they have
a if they if they do get pregnant then
um I would say up to maybe just before
12 weeks or up to 12 weeks because there
must be a reason why you have your first
scan that 12 weeks I'm not sure exactly
the scientific yeah stuff behind it but
there must be a reason why you don't see
anything like about a heartbeat like if
I go if there was complications or at
one point I was like six weeks and I
started spotting I spottings when you
start seeing blood when you're pregnant
um then you would go and get an exam or
when you go to get that exam because
it's an early pregnancy scam you can't
even go and get a scan on your belly
they actually put like this special
camera inside you because it's too small
to see anything so if your child is if
child embryo what everyone has their
different tones but when um fetus is
that small I would I would say in my
head it would sit right with me I have a
nephew that was premature and he was
born at six months old and my nephew was
Tiny he weighed about
the same
way as a bag of sugar literally he was
Tiny like that so he was like so he was
like so you would agree that the six
months at least yeah like six months is
too much for me because when my nephew
was born he was a baby like he was in an
incubator so I have a question for a
woman that aborts a kid after six months
should she face jail time
um no that see that's touchy obviously
certain people go through certain
traumatic experiences which would make
them maybe angry in in that sense but I
don't think a woman should go to jail
for having whatever [__] what if
what if um the mom has the kid and then
the Dad throws it off of a bridge should
he go to jail
if the woman has the kid at six months
old and then the Dad throws it off the
bridge should he go to jail well of
course that's murder
wouldn't it be the same thing though no
because when it's still it's still
inside of the woman
it hasn't it's still inside of the woman
it's a part of the woman so the woman
can still use to hold my body my choice
when she's physically giving birth that
is a human entity on its own yeah
Breathing by itself doing everything by
itself so then so then so then that
would go out of location then shouldn't
you just Legalize It Up to nine months
no like the day before she gives birth
she says no because I hear what you're
saying however I think that because due
to the development and how a baby is
developed I think it's more Humane to do
it when the the fetus or whatever the
terminology is hasn't fully developed
into a child yeah I still am pro-choice
there needs to be a certain stop to it
I'm I'm for it for three months all
right I may be four at a push yeah but
no so my only question is I'm just
curious why there would not if you don't
if you think it should be illegal at six
right which I think we would agree on
right six months is too far along yeah
I'm just curious should not make that
decision it just seems like whenever
there's a consequence for women like we
always want to bail women out no no no
no so it's like when when there would be
a legal consequence then we're like oh
no that's too far no no I watched
something yesterday on on Prime and it
was about um a woman who basically
um was uh obsessed with this guy so much
to the point where I'm pretty sure I
haven't finished the series yet but I'm
pretty sure she commits suicide in order
to frame him now I know there's some
women that do deserve to be reprimanded
for their actions however being pregnant
and I have that you don't know the
reason how someone's got pregnant you
don't know their finances even even it
could be rape as well even in the
example with the guy you don't know the
reason why he wanted to throw the kid
off the bridge yeah that's got to be
some type of mental problem right but
I'm correct but I'm saying we all have
reasons we commit crimes but if that was
a crime like why would she not have a
punishment yeah some people commit
crimes because of money some people
commit crimes because of Revenge some
people commit crowns for madness we
don't know however I think abortion is
is not necessarily a crime it can't be
compared to physically throwing a human
being off of a well it could be if it
was illegal like it is a crime after
there's a girl that's going to jail
right now
um overtaking the abortion pills too
late so it is a crime sorry go ahead
um well you guys can interject too if
you have anything go ahead I was um
I was gonna say like the
The Madness of
you know about rapists right yes you
know about they have actual rights
over
so grapists grape someone
they get pregnant
they the rapist and The Grapist family
have rights over the child that they've
just created through grape
can we ever be saying grapes on
Wednesday I'm sorry it's not funny uh is
that true if he's true he's convicted
he's convicted and if you look into it
there is a family that ended up fighting
for custody of their son who raped this
young girl
over the the child and they got
visitation rights and they got like
excuse me like you've they imagine just
imagine how traumatized you would be
anyway
and then you have to do you have to did
he go to jail for it
that store yeah that one that I read he
got convicted okay so his his mum I'm
just surprised his mom oh his mom was
like the one that said I want to be in
the child's life and they said no as you
would
and she was and she was allowed to see
the baby now it's like you've heard it
vice versa where a female teacher well
grape so so tell me about it you can put
the kid on child support and she yeah
and the amount of the amount of
disgusting disgusting
families right females that do it
and they get nothing because they're a
girl because it's a woman and it's like
I don't know yeah
it's in in it in a in a chronographic
way it's like oh my head like my old
teacher my older teacher fancy Smith
when it's a younger boy and an older
woman right but if you switch it and it
there's Opera like everyone's like
that's gonna stand now oh my gosh like
get him arrested these women are going
into prison and then getting sent money
daily from these weird old guys yeah
that are like oh I wish that you as my
teacher and sending them money and
they're now like glorified like it's
like look who tells you the Ted Bundy
oh yeah I know I know they do yeah I
know that it's it's a problem because
it's but the grapest thing that's
another reason why I think they should
that's why that's one pushing me to one
side it's like if you want to keep that
child and and it's a child of grape cool
that's your I shouldn't have access to
it exactly she has to she has to then
see this rapist for the rest of her life
right yeah yeah it does sound though
that oh that sounds really traumatic I
definitely agree with that but it does
send the solution to that though is a
legal issue related to parental rights
and the solution is not abortion in that
situation
what would it be well it would it it
it's not really abortion until I'm
saying my point is that could be a
problem that like I didn't have access
so I wasn't able to get an abortion and
now I'm having to have this child with a
Grapist
um sure yeah no I understand that would
be a really difficult situation to be in
um but again it sounds well firstly it
does sound like a better solution to
tackle that is obviously reducing rate
first of all I accept that that will
never be zero percent
um but even with the with the problem
that you're raising again this sounds
like a a problem that we need to tackle
with kind of rapist rights
um rather than than say abortion is a
solution to that and you know in that
situation I don't think it's a solution
at all right well I'm my point is just
that there's a lot of these girls that
talk about it have said they've not had
access I just so I just think at the end
of the day 90 of abortions nowadays are
elective and they're women making bad
decisions can I I just think it's like
well yeah I think it's women being very
honestly because we went around and
everybody said the reasons why they got
an abortion and are their friends got an
abortion and the majority was wrong
partner a wrong time so it kind of
sounds like a responsible can I just say
like toxic Partners they're not always
obvious in the beginning so you might
think someone is great you have a child
like later down the line and then
they're toxic like if you see these
warning signs surely you know get out
sooner but but it does sometimes and I
would have a lot of sympathy if those
women
um asked their parents for their advice
because half the time these women they
won't ask their parents advice and when
their parents give them advice and say
no that's a bad guy they don't listen to
some circumstances there's not um not
everywhere not everyone can can get
advice from their parents exactly I'm
not saying every single person but I am
saying I see that often and in the
majority of times in toxic relationships
I just see women not listening but you
also have to consider them some of their
friends will say something too they'll
be like yeah I mean I'm sure all of you
have said something to a friend that
that boyfriend is toxic or crazy and the
women don't listen 100 but you also have
to think about the woman as well and
there's Sometimes women are in
vulnerable situations people deal with
mental health they maybe can't feel like
they can't leave there's a lot of
difference no I know but to me this is
just excuses when at the end of the day
it's you making a choice and I think
you're responsible for the choices you
make you know do you know sorry to cut
you you know what not every woman is
strong there's a lot of weak women out
here okay and they're weak for all
different type of reasons yeah and
they're not able to
see a good man yeah a lot of these women
might have had a really bad relationship
and then instead of taking the necessary
time to heal they get into another
relationship and what happens is they
see this person this new guy as
something amazing because he's probably
better than the last one who was abusive
yeah but the next guy still isn't Prince
Charming still isn't going to be there
still might be there for two three years
yeah but but but it takes it takes a bit
though my thing is like take
responsibility for your choices I hear
you but you you have to understand that
some people are not very intelligent
some people don't are not awakened to
certain things they just make terrible
decisions but I just hear that's an
excuse but what's about the men in this
like what I mean aren't they also
responsible for I mean yeah exactly it's
like
is the woman is the woman supposed to
make sure that the male wears them and
also you know it contrast they also have
to yes I do think you should make sure
that the person you're sleeping with is
wearing is responsibility and you're
right we could say we're condom equally
responsible fine fine we'll agree with
that but you know with the women we have
plan B we have abortion
um we also have um we also have um what
do you call it what 44 forms of birth
control we have all these different we
can get the thing in your arm you can
get an IUD you can take the pill
I just I don't know if women can't get
any contraceptive though it's free I'm
sorry I don't know if there's things
can I sorry but if we look at the
numbers 53 percent of women aren't
wearing a condom with a new partner can
I have to me that just screams
irresponsible
contraceptions what are they using all
the contraception I I don't know
you know what else can I can I just say
I think
um I think you write about I think I
think that the abortion
being pushed the way it is has
encouraged
people being promiscuous I think that
there is a lot of stupid girls and guys
out there that are sleeping around that
uh like oh it's my whole face like and
like hot girls summer and all these it's
it's promoting
bad
nasty yeah it's basically like
promiscuous behavior and one out of
three women have had an abortion like
it's a form of birth control at this
point well the younger is getting
younger and younger and younger yeah and
I think that there is so many girls that
I'd say that girls that are now probably
10 to 15 in like 10 years time they're
gonna have had like 10 plus abortions
that want girls that are for abortion
but there is a lot of girls that I have
heard you know in school that I've
spoken to from high school that I've
already had like two three abortions and
they're in high school yeah and and
they're not it's it's nothing to them
it's like oops like just get another one
oh it's happened again pro-choice people
can we have an abortion cap like after
three now no do you know you need to
keep this child this is just
irresistible do you know what um
abortion medication is
do you know what it does which what do
you mean well abortion medication it
induces right so it's not this special
pill that goes and just kills the fetus
it causes the body of the mother to
eject it right so it's not killing it
it's making the area in which it's
growing in a hospitable
so which does what
well it rejects it it causes a
miscarriage right so that does what
well then the argument is it was it
alive because we have to we have to
Define what being alive is and whether
so I see a pregnancy as a potential life
not as a life until something sitting in
front of me it's not a life that doesn't
mean that I don't can make
considerations for how we perceive women
who are pregnant especially later on in
pregnancy those two things are not
particularly related and my opinions are
more on a societal basis and not from
any argument from Consciousness or
really that much bodily autonomy for
example if we say oh well it will
definitely survive at six months um
although that already is the cut off
in which case I said some some children
survived at like five and a half months
before well then I I have no issue with
potential C-sections or whatever
happening at any point in time but the
reality is like they're gonna live so
there's no point speculating about eight
or nine month abortions because that
wouldn't make any sense sorry they'll
cut you what did you say your name was
again sorry uh Kelly Kelly
um on Google it says that they're on
Google
says
no I'm just saying legally you can't get
a birth certificate for a death of a
child unless it's
um like actually being born so if you
have like a still bath or you have like
um like say you want to carry through
with your pregnancy and you get to like
five six months you're excited about
your pregnancy you've told everyone
about your pregnancy you're looking
forward to your child coming your child
dies you haven't given birth to your
child you're really telling me I can't
get a death certificate for my child and
to me that's my child you know what I
mean I want to mourn like and stuff like
that so if
um with um pro-life
um people that are with pro-life it's
like it's a when you said um sorry when
you said a childlike is not really like
a person until they're born
so what about the moms that think that
that child is a person they're growing
with a baby inside of their belly they
want to like have some kind of nothing
to stop anyone for a morning but laughs
regardless but you don't have a death
certificate
for your child so how do you you can't
have a funeral you can't really have a
funeral you can still have a funeral I
know but it's not really like like
something for yourself like say you you
want to have something to keep that to
say I had this baby that this existed
this happened you know I mean you can't
really have that so it's like saying oh
before my child's born my child's not a
child but if my child's not a child then
how can people really argue and say that
abortion is wrong if the child's not a
child then you've made you've made a
really good point because you've said
about
um you can't get a birth certificate
until you're born so I understand a
death certificate if the child dies and
you haven't given birth to that child
yet during your pregnancy yeah yeah yeah
that makes sense is that that makes
sense to me in my mind logically that
makes perfect sense why would you get a
death certificate if you haven't
received a birth certificate well but
what is
tell me about it so the child hasn't
been been born yet then technically
that's if the child hasn't been born yet
then you're saying that's not in life
and some people saying that's not alive
it has not been born yet so if someone
has it's a living organism yes depending
on how far along it is but it has not
been born don't get interested I'm
pro-choice don't get twisted I'm poor
choice what I'm saying what I'm saying
is for people that are pro-life if you
have an abortion before the child is
born that is wrong right for you to have
an abortion before you've given birth to
a child so there's some of the some of
the same people that are also pro-life
will not they'll they're with like not
how can you not have a death certificate
it's not a child right you get what I'm
trying to say if it's not alive if it's
not like I don't know if I'm you can
explain what I'm trying to say probably
to get what I'm trying to say I sort of
do sort of that so you're saying why why
don't they have a death certificate yes
if the child is in if if in your eyes
the child is alive is considered a child
before the child's being born then that
child when it dies before being born
should be should be allowed a death
certificate to say that this child was
something this child existed right you
know what I mean but it's not it's
illegal but in certain countries it's
illegal to have an abortion but it's
also illegal to have a death certificate
before 24 weeks it doesn't make sense
it's it's all hypocritical all of it the
the life the choice the likely to like
we just said that I don't know if you
heard but if a woman gets killed and
she's pregnant she could have just
become pregnant the day before I think
they find out I think the problems are
not hypocritical I think it makes
perfect sense because we would say it's
a double homicide and we would say make
sure there should be a death certificate
yeah well they should be but then
how come you don't get a death
certificate yeah if you don't get a
death certificate before 24 weeks then
how could it be a double homicide
imagine the late the woman was literally
like a month pregnant right but I think
pro-lifers would support the idea of
having that death certificate to to be
able to mourn that child properly but
also I think a broader question at the
center of this is is what makes a child
alive right because that's what really
matters if can you get a death
certificate after you've been alive
that's the logical thing so is it that
you are you're aware of your
surroundings is it that you can feel
pain is it that you have 10 fingers and
ten toes what is it that makes you alive
is it that your heart is beating so to
you
um at what point in a pregnancy would
you class
um a pregnancy as a life in inside of
you what at what point would that be so
I would start all the way from
conception that that is a new distinct
on whole human being it's it's not it's
mum it's not it's dead it's a new uh
human being and as that develops along
the way I think heart starts beating we
know as early as even three weeks uh we
now believe from from Recent research
search at 15 weeks maybe even before
then they can already feel pain I just
think that through a little bit
logically for us are you a human if you
don't have a sex yet are you what would
you be classed as if you don't have asex
could you yeah you're not a human yet by
the way so you're not a human because
you don't you don't find out the sex of
your child until you're 25 years the mum
doesn't but the the child actually has
it sex right from the start so it
depends on its chromosomes if it has XX
or X Y so right from the moment that
human being comes into formation it's
already it's not a human it's not a
human being
there's a unique DNA code that's created
that's different from the mom and the
dads from conception yeah so that and
like in that code they can say their eye
color their hair color their height
that's fine but that's all just cells
it's not an actual human being yeah but
to the same extent I'm I'm also cells I
mean we are all cells but we're also
we're now human beings right you
understand well
we're adults I think that's the
distinction we're making no because a
plant is also alive but a plant is still
a plant a baby is alive but it hasn't
been born yet and it also has an
experience
things are quite simple yeah it hasn't
been born it's not left the model it's
still inside of the mother's body it's a
part of the mother it's it's breathing
and eating and getting everything from
the mother if the mother dies the child
will die right yeah so to a certain
extent if the child's already a certain
amount of weeks I have heard in some
cases
um historically that the child can be
born certain if the mother has died life
if it's not really far along but what
I'm saying is you know in in terms of a
brought in at three to four months which
is something that I agree with you know
um the the child the baby or the embryo
or whatever it is correct terminology is
fully reliant on that sure and it's
still part of the mother's body right so
let's explore that a little bit more so
we've got it hasn't had experiences and
it's still relies on its mother and
those are the two things that we know
that's not what I'm saying because we
some people are allowing their mother
till death and you know some you know
some people don't have a lot of
experience I don't know because she's
trying to um summarize my what I'm
trying to say in this incorrectly how
you've summarized it yeah what I'm
trying to say is to you that we have to
remember that the the the embryo is not
a baby and is not a human until a
certain point that's not true okay go on
King
tell us all right because you made a
point you said a plant is a plant and uh
uh whatever you said about the humans
that the embryo Is Not a Human Being yet
but to come against that point a seed
is where the plants come from right you
can't get a human being from a seed and
you can't get a plant from an embryo I
can make a better comparison if I would
like go for it but can I just say can I
just that to come against your own point
because you said
um I believe you said
um
it's not murder because the woman is
ejecting the baby that I can I can use
an analogy the medicine is inducing yes
but I can use this analogy if if someone
was hanging over this ledge there and
they were about to fall to their death
and I ejected them I didn't kill them I
didn't shoot them in the head I didn't
do anything but I just pushed the the
room that were they killing them why
it's the same thing I'm ejecting them no
it's not your it's not yours it's not
come from you and this is what you're
trying to use all of these examples then
I can eject yeah if we're going to use
this whole my body my choice here you
can't keep using these if I'm a human
being and I'm going to push another
human being it's not the same no but
when we don't use it but you're okay
with her using a comparison you're using
a comparison to plants but we can't use
this comparison because we're talking
about being alive we're talking about
being alive and a plant is alive yeah
you know a plant is still alive you know
we're cells we're all cells actually so
is the person being ejected off the
building yeah yeah yeah
comparison than a plant no it's not it's
not you you what you have to understand
is that when I said about the plant I
said that in regards to being a a living
organism yeah so an embryo human being a
cat a plant we're all living yeah the
experiences that we have is is different
because with different types of living
organisms yeah when you said about
um uh at conception this is the point
where it becomes a human being I
disagree with you personally because at
that point it's just cells merging
creating what would be a human being now
now sorry King I'm not too sure when it
actually because I don't know about
these things too deep I just have my
opinions however
whenever that cell that embryo starts to
form into a baby with a heartbeat and
starts to get organs like lungs and so
forth and and Limbs and so forth I think
there should be a certain point where
the abortion doesn't become an option I
think that women need to and Men or
whoever's involved mainly the women
because as I said is her body her choice
need to make these decisions fast you
know you you have these decisions
firstly before you even sleep with the
person but if it's still too late you
need to make these decisions quickly I'm
gonna like King go ahead yeah but is a
cell because you're conflating the your
point is a cell a living organism a cell
is but it's not a human being is it a
living organism I said it already so how
can you in the same breath say something
is a living organism but it can't be
murdered
because it's not a human being I didn't
say that it can't be murdered you're
putting my words in my mouth what I said
what I said is a cell from the young
lady who's who said that um from con
from conception conception thank you
from conception it's a human being my
whole uh my whole my whole my whole
spill has been because of that statement
yeah but that's semantics human being
living on a guy it's not semantics
because when we're talking about
abortion and killing human beings
it's so because these are names of
things so a cell is a living organism
right correct a human being is what also
a living organism exactly so but they're
not the same it doesn't matter why
because we're talking about life we're
not talking about whether it's a human
life or a plant like what's in my life
it's if I talk about life and then
because you're conflating it so if we're
talking about life and then you're
saying a cell is a living organism if
you cannot compare a cell to a human
being then that means you should be able
to get a plant out of a cell right I'm
gonna come I'm gonna respond to you so a
life is not the same as a living
organism or I don't know if I'm saying
this red correctly it's not that they're
not they're not the same things yes but
you're conflict things that actually
don't matter whether you call it a life
or a living organism or a human being
doesn't matter all these are are just
words that we used to express ourselves
further to develop further points to be
able to communicate better but the basis
the basic ideology is that you can only
get a human being from the cells that
are grown in a woman's womb the reasons
get a plant I'll get you and the reason
why I do hold on to words is because
it's Words which impact people's
opinions so much when you're talking
about killing human beings it sounds
Savage and it sounds wrong yeah because
but that's not but that's not what's
happening with abortion at three three
months in my opinion how'd you know
because is it a human being and that's
my argument when when it becomes a human
being that's when we're talking about
that's a good question is like when is a
human sorry I just saw that well I'd
love to give a medical so I'm a medical
doctor and we study this in medical
school you know when does a human being
begin to exist when does an organism
begin to exist we learn it begins at
conception there was no real debate
about that it's only when you get into
the politics of abortion that people are
like oh we don't know we don't know when
it's alive we don't know when it's a
human being in it from a medical
perspective in medical school in my
medical practice is very obvious when I
see a lady who's pregnant if she wants
the baby she can be only five weeks
along you go on the NHS website it says
you and your baby at five weeks this is
what it's like and so I think all of us
readily accept in every other context
that this is a living human being
I don't think anyone denies that except
when it comes to abortion because it's
you know pro-choices need to say it's
not that because you know the the
reality is is difficult to reconcile
with the pro-choice views so there was
even a survey of this a few years ago of
biologists this is a biological question
right biology literally means the study
of life they studied 6 000 biologists
around the world and they said are you
pro-life or pro-choice and half of them
pro-life half of them pro-choice
probably more pro-choice and they said
when does an individual member of the
human species begin to exist like what
else could human being mean an
individual human organism of the species
Homo sapiens and 95 of them said at
fertilization we know that this is a
human because it's homo sapiens it's not
any other species it's not a cat or a
dog or a elephant we know that it's
living because it can die and we all
know what it means when a baby dies in
the womb it's a living it's human what
more does it need to be a human being
it's got everything that I've got I hear
you it's not fully developed and I think
that that when we're looking at some of
the reasons why women have abortions and
some of the conditions uh human beings
that have been born are living in
for me personally it makes me understand
why people why women are having
abortions and it makes me think what
makes me be pro-choice yeah because
uh if what you're saying is true I'm not
disputing that scientifically maybe so
however in my opinion I still do believe
that women should have a choice to abort
a child whether it's at home as long as
it's safe or you know in a medical
facility up to a certain point you know
what I mean yeah so I think you know we
can obviously disagree about and or
agree about when abortion is okay but I
think we can still agree on what this is
that we're talking about I don't think
we need to sort of distort the reality
and say it's not a human being or
something I'm not accusing you of
deliberately doing that
um but I really think you know we have
to get these basic biological facts
agreed upon because otherwise we're
never going to agree on anything and you
know this is a baby from about 16 days
the baby's heart begins to pump blood
around the body at six weeks it begins
to Hiccup and suck and swallow maybe
seven weeks from four to five weeks it's
beginning to move by itself from about
10 weeks it can probably feel pain and
it's conscious there's all these things
it develops very quickly but if you want
to say oh it's only a full human being
when it's fully developed well if
science again shows us a human's brain
is not typically fully developed until
they're 25 years old so some of you gen
Z people were not fully developed
um I doubt even I am to be honest but
you know we don't allow
people to distinguish between humans and
say you're valuable you're not you have
a right to life you're you don't on how
developed they are I'm more developed
than some of you not because I'm more
intelligent but because I'm just older
and you know heading towards death
gradually that doesn't make me more of a
human it doesn't give me more of a right
to life it just means I'm older but we
are equal because we're equal human
beings and the pro-life view just says
that's the same of every human being
that we're all equal no matter how
developed no matter how big no matter
how independent we are all human beings
and therefore we're all equal the mother
and the baby and so the pro-lifer has to
say that Mother matters infinitely the
baby matters infinitely and we have to
do our best to try and protect both
um so I'm I don't find the Consciousness
argument very compelling just for the
record but I've never read anything that
suggests that there's Consciousness at
10 weeks um the earliest I've read is 20
weeks
um so
I it's not that I do not believe that
there is a type of Life there but I
think it's very strange that we're all
considering that it will be a guaranteed
baby at the end of it so the reason why
I consider
a fetus especially in the earlier stages
to be a potential life is because 20 of
all pregnancies end in a miscarriage
anyway but I mean there's also a number
of other things that could happen in
this span of time
um and I mean stillbirths is still one
in 175 as well if you're particularly
unlucky as and removing all variables
though
um so for something to be a life uh that
we find I guess valuable
it makes sense to consider viability and
certainly an embryo is not what do you
mean by viability
it could breathe
if it if it can sustain its own system
by itself okay and that doesn't and that
is not the same as the fact that a
mother needs to feed it and such I guess
though that does get difficult if we
because we're talking here about what
makes a life life and that's actually a
pretty important legal question later on
where I think about human rights
violations right who gets to have human
rights as a you know as a human person
outside of the womb and if we're saying
that a human is only a human only
deserves the right to life if they're a
conscience conscious or if they are
breathing and supporting their own body
on their own without any help from
anyone that puts in a very difficult
situation people who are lying in comas
in a very difficult situation it's not
the same like it's not the same you're
using all of these analogies it's not
the same okay so what about conjoined
twins
okay so twins there's many legal cases
on this these are twins that have shared
organs maybe one of them is using the
other one's heart they're fully
dependent they're linked by their bodies
it's a very intimate relationship that
doesn't just go on for nine months it
goes on for the entirety of their lives
and yet the law has been completely
clear if you have a sister that is
sharing your heart and that is using
your heart the law is absolutely clear
you cannot kill them even though they're
dependent on you they can't sustain
themselves they're invading your body in
a very if you're sharing a heart they
would die you'd both die that was I mean
yeah that's a
I mean there are cases like you know
sharing a liver for example so you know
there's a there's a there was born like
that that's how they that's a uh however
that is the same can you kill one and
keep the other anyway though that
doesn't make sense if one dies both of
them Dino I think he's talking about
conjoined twins no but even if they're
conjoined like how is that even a choice
like when you have like they're still
twins yeah you know what I mean no so if
you're even thinking about abortion by
them thinking about twins you would only
think about that if you're thinking
about getting rid of both of them you
couldn't make a choice of oh I'm gonna
get rid of one and keep the other anyway
even no no someone might do that no but
is that even possible it's actually
quite common yeah we know because the
department of health keeps pretty good
statistics on abortion and says why
every single abortion is done
the NHS website if you look it's called
selective reduction or multiple
pregnancy and quite a few abortions each
year are done basically because there
are too many babies and they have to get
rid of some so hold on just based on
what you said because I I actually
understood your when after you made it
um what she's saying is it true like can
you if you've got twins growing in you
and you decide to kill one of them and
can you keep the other twin alive yeah
because I actually don't know if you can
do that yeah it's quite common but then
really it's possible
but really see this is actually this is
things like that that's the reason why I
would kind of understand why science has
really gone because that would be
pro-life because
who would really want to make that
decision what kind of person does that
if you have twins you have twins
yeah but then if it's Financial don't
have a baby but some people might have
only planned to have money for one yeah
I mean I mean I'm not saying I'm just
really shocked I didn't know it was
scientifically possible
when they made when they made abortion
it was supposed to be like safe rare
like it wasn't supposed to be like I
just think it's gotten ridiculous to the
point one out of three women are having
them it's birth control how many
abortions can you even have that's
another thing I want to say I can't
remember the exact number but it's
roughly 40 percent of women that have
had abortions I've had two or more so no
but is there a cat born it can I'm sure
damage your body or something like I
mean I'm pretty sure it must definitely
something yeah yeah well and and I've
heard stories of girls out of eight nine
abortions and that's what I'm saying
like it's not even safe and rare anymore
it's just women making poor decisions so
in the 1980s the average woman in
Romania has eight abortions that was the
average woman wait in Romania Romania in
the 1980s or maybe 1960s why was there
no contraception there was no
contraception okay well that makes sense
yeah I mean yeah so they they you know
there was no contraceptions but they
could have abortions
why did they do that well and I just
think all of these reasons just come to
be excuses when it's just like we can
close our legs we don't have to make
children with like these bad guys
in the middle sorry no I agree with you
probably it sounds like a blaming women
sometimes yeah
it makes two together but it's like why
can't we start with the women before we
go to the men we always talk about men's
but men are legally responsible if they
get a girl pregnant they have to pay
child support So after after we we both
get pregnant that's equally as long as
they're working women
wait listen listen if we if we get
pregnant it's equally irresponsible
right I mean I would argue it's more on
the women but we'll for that for that
well I mean when you think about I know
okay think about it we got we got 10
choices they have condom no condom we
know when we ovulate we can get on birth
control we can do plan B did you know
that we can do an abortion adoption like
we have all these choices the men have
won did you know that the
um contraception pill was actually
designed for men originally it was okay
but can they take it now but the thing
is I wow there it is
I think actually that they decided that
well you probably know better than me
that it was better for the women to take
it because like the the men didn't want
to have no in that study it was like one
or two of them died I want to say so
that was why they had to cut it because
some women died as well yeah
I don't
I don't man I think it's more I think
the reason is a bit more common sensical
like it's I think it's easier to
um
to lock off one egg than 100 million
sperm
I just think that's the reason why it's
harder to find contraceptive for me no
no they they made it work it's just that
men didn't like the side effects effects
of uh birth control
no but there was it was sterilization
and one or two people died in that study
so that's why they were like way worse
than the side effects for women
suicidality is a side effect for women's
birth control when 90 of women are on it
I just don't think it's that common
especially when men commit suicide more
so the women we need to raise our voice
women trying to yeah the contraception
as well women try to con to commit
suicide more but they tend to be less
successful because they don't pick
lethal methods well I think it so so men
are better at suicide than us is that
true that at that point is true but if
we're on societal arguments that is sort
of where my
um interest is so when it comes to
thinking okay so what benefits are there
if we ban abortion well theoretically
that would potentially be more kids that
could be a bonus um the birth rate is
falling in a lot of developed countries
but when I think of what the negatives
are
um it's significantly more in my opinion
for women if you start to take away
these types of Rights they are going to
naturally feel oppressed it's going to
reduce the things that they do they're
going to change the behavior they're
going to be having sex less
relationships less and already gen Z is
having relationships less and sex less
so it might not necessarily maybe
they'll maybe they'll even marry babies
maybe their marriage rates falling as
well well if we ban divorce I think
maybe it would go back up that's a whole
different time
yeah but if I'm honest sorry I'll just
finish my point quickly
um I don't think abortion rate will drop
I think that legal abortions will drop
because obviously they won't be
available which means more women are
going to have medical side effects from
procuring illegal abortion drugs
I think women more women in jail I think
women might think twice before maybe
sleeping with the whole football
I think I think one out of three
abortions is a lot of abortions
I understand and you know I think we
should punish people that get those I
think that should be illegal too you
know that the prosecution rate for all
crime in general is pretty abysmal right
it's just it's it pays to be a criminal
we can we can make the process can I
just say
um an unpopular opinion
um
amongst women
uh but I have heard it time and time
again from Men which is you know that
breakups are harder for men than it is
on women and the reason is because women
are the ones with the choice so women
choose who they sleep with like we have
more Choice whether so if we say no
unless you're graped
we say no and that's it the men have to
beg and they and take us and where was
and do this and that and we what are the
ones and we're the only ones that know
when we're ovulating to you can only get
pregnant like five days a month yeah but
we also know if you're a birth control
or not a lot of women lie about it yeah
yeah they do they do and we also can he
can't make you take a plan B so we have
all these choices so before I get
attacked by women yeah I'm not saying
that I'm not saying that like you know
do Bell I'm just saying that I've been
told from many men and I was thinking
yeah you're right they're not like
whoever we have slept with women
we unless it's been some you know a
different situation
um in a normal situation we know we're
the ones that have said okay
okay
it's always on the woman
so the woman has the last say
in sex
and we know when we're on we know when
what we're taking we know what we're so
it's like if you're going to have sex
with I mean sorry sex uh if you're gonna
sleep with someone and then you you
uh not on the pill
he's not wearing a condom
you're not on anything and you still
don't go and get the morning after pill
or you don't whatever you and then go oh
I'm pregnant
like damn I don't think I'm shocked how
did that happen I know I like
I know I'm in this situation
right that's that's what I say it's
because we have all of these choices to
prevent these things like yet we will
still say but men when I bring this up
you just said something that made me
think so if you if women get the law say
in during intercourse do you think women
should get the law say when it comes to
if they have an abortion or not
see I've spoken about this a lot I don't
I think it might show up on that one
that was actually my next question yeah
like serious it is um I think that the
that
if the the partner has an issue I think
if the woman says I want an abortion and
the boyfriend is like I don't want an
abortion
then I would say for the woman to go and
do it that's
okay but what if they both agreed to
have an abortion and then the woman
decides okay I'm gonna keep the baby now
I know many of those
I know many is she wrong for the women
is she wrong I think uh
well you know what's interesting women
have the right not to be mothers but men
don't have the right not to be fathers
because a woman can get an abortion and
say I don't want to be a mother but a
man can't opt out of Child Support or he
goes to jail or gets his assets seized
yeah yeah that's not in that angle the
way how you pass out yeah like and then
you're complaining that some people are
pro-life you can't really have a
complaint from both sides if you're
pro-life then you're going to want women
to do that right you can't criticize
women for both things no no I actually I
would ban child support actually yeah
yeah yeah I would say I would say I
would say I make supports for the church
yeah well I would if women were just if
women were really just spending child
support on the child they might support
that but yeah
and and
500 I mean maybe you make a lot of money
you're an internet person you know but
for the average guy that's a lot in a
month 500 bucks a month but you think
that's a lot for sustaining a child
I think if you can afford the child you
should have custody of it so if she
can't afford the child give it to the
dad the reason that the dad can't afford
it is because he's at work all the time
and how can you look after a kid with
you guys but that's my point it should
be his responsibility so if he wants to
let the mom watch it when he wants her
to then right you can fight it's really
not a thing here it's it's they only get
custody 10 of the time so so 50 50. well
the reason they don't is because they go
broke doing it and a lot of them a lot
of lawyers advise them not to I mean
I've interviewed guys that like go
through this it's not an easy process I
think the reality is it's very hard to
sustain that because if you're a man and
you're working full-time um it's not
worth to fight it unless you're willing
to work less or lose your job or do a
different job like so when you're
looking at it from this perspective one
of the two has to work and if you're the
one with the better job you're going to
opt out of that as a choice well I I
just don't think you should be rewarded
for making a poor choice so I think you
know if you can if you can let's listen
to me and not make it a kid let's make
it a dog if I can afford a dog then I
get the dog why why should you why
should you get the kid if you can't
afford it and it's like it's like it's
almost like it's almost like
it's almost like punishing men for doing
the right thing they're supposed to work
they're doing the right thing and now
we're punishing them and saying no you
can't have the kid because you're
working but a kid needs more than just
money right you need to be it's the
caring well okay okay well then if we're
gonna put the kid first then the Dad
should definitely get it because single
father homes produce better children
than single mother homes thank you
because the men that do take it on have
the capabilities to be there I mean I
mean that's the reason that they're
usually really rich that's the reason
that the left gives but you just said
it's not about money and now you're
saying it's money because if you already
have the money then you don't have to
work
true
there's good Rich parents there's good
poor parents
that's not the same I think she likes to
conflict a lot of things I don't think
most of the fathers that raise their
kids on their own are rich I actually
think it's the opposite because more
time more often than not if uh if a man
is rich he he he can have the mother
take care of the kid the mother doesn't
have to work he doesn't have to be with
her that's what would usually happen
being a man knowing a lot of men are in
that situation I know that's what
usually happened most of the men that
raised kids on their own are struggling
of course it's a struggle for both yeah
it's not equal so it's like if we my
whole point is it's not equal so it's
like okay if we if if the feminists the
left would ever want abortion to be
legal then then why then then let the
men not be fathers too the thing is like
until I'm not too sure like honestly I'm
not I'd really like to know the type of
men that you're speaking about because
the women that I know
of whether I know of them personally I
mean they're single mothers like they're
begging their father they're begging
their baby father for money towards like
summer camp for the kids because these
dads think that they're the mother's
whole life should revolve around the
children when he does the bare minimum
like I said before why can't she have a
life it's like all of these men why did
she open her legs for him my thing is
women have all the choice when it comes
to sex it is not hard for us to get sex
but this is why every every half
attractive chick has five dudes and her
friends on the chicken date can I can I
ask can I ask what's your opinion on
Grape then like if it's not in the
women's control
what do you then think grape grape is a
bit irritating people always bring this
up and it because it's less than point
five percent of abortion but it doesn't
so you're right I'll tell you my opinion
but I'm saying if you know it's
frustrating because it's like okay if we
give you grape will you guys get rid of
the 99.5 of abortions and I know the
answer to that is no so I just think
people do that as a way to discredit the
right but
um no great I would have no exceptions
what your guys views on
um say a girl
says that she's on uh contraception
but then
um and then the guy doesn't use a condom
oh wait actually no sorry did use a
condom and the girl holes
in it is that what you're getting that
turkey baster
what is so for the dad who is now a dad
and he didn't want to be a dad and he
asked and made sure are you on
contraception yes okay and they still
put our condom on and she's poked holes
or turkey-based dude
um you know that kind of thing
and as people say trapped the the dad
and then he is not a great dad
but then she trapped him I'm actually
you know what I was thinking about I was
thinking about how they make laws where
if a guy removes the condom without a
woman's consent that's considered grape
yet a woman lying to a man about birth
control is not considered yes isn't that
crazy this is why this is so that's what
I was that's serious that is an actual
thing if you interfere with the condom
it is a crime but it's but it's to prove
so it is but you would agree that's a
double standard right yeah that is a
double standard 100 because if you're
long enough yeah not today but they're
both primes no no but I'm asking would
you say it's a double stand it's not a
crime for a woman to do that the birth
control is not a crime lying about birth
control well yeah that that's not an
unethical but you shouldn't just blindly
believe I mean you were the one who
do you think do you think that's a
double standard that's my question
please no please get stupidity on the
men's part okay so this is already okay
even if they're dating them like this is
a lot of times this happens to men that
have been well
it's unethical it's deceptive it's
manipulative but you probably shouldn't
be dating someone like that right well
then could only say that to the women
like you shouldn't be dating someone
people shouldn't date bad people yes
if you're saying it's it's a crime if
the guy if
you said you kind of defended the other
one you kind of gave the woman the out
again but my point is if the guy's own
is bad for taking off the condom you
said it can be proved if the woman
interferes with the condom so how does
the woman prove that the guy took off
the condom after the fact
I think he
um well it is it's incredibly hard to
prove but if there is semen inside the
woman then she can go get checked at the
hospital
there's a condom no there's not a condom
no no
it's hard to convict for sexual assault
in general so you can't prove it because
when you're going to prove it you're not
going to be in there how did the condom
get off you're not listening if she's
going to have to go and prove it then
she has to bring evidence so how does
that matter so if you imagine not having
sex with somebody and they've got you
and say a particular position where you
can't see them for example they're not
face to face now
um you have now stopped having sex you
guys have intercourse sorry I don't even
know if I can really say that can I say
that yeah yeah so you guys are having
you guys are finished doing what you're
doing and obviously he's released you've
released climax or whatever you realize
he's not wearing a condom now there's
only two things there's only two ways
that can go it's either the condom has
slipped off inside of you
or the condom has come off and how's the
condom gonna magically come again with
that I know but I'm saying like but if
they've taken a condom off then that's
the pre-frame
she said that the guy won't be able to
prove that the woman interfered with the
condom okay agreed I thought it would be
hard you kind of candles
kind of can finish let him finish okay
hard to prove that the woman interfered
with the condom I think it's equally as
hard to prove that the man took off the
condom because how do you sh how do you
prove to the Lord that okay this man
took off the condom because semen is not
proof because there are people that have
gotten pregnant even when the condom was
still on yeah so when a guy takes off a
condom
and it's got semen inside of it if there
was a hole in the condom wouldn't you
notice that
it's like the Siemens coming out of the
condom when you see a hole like it's
seeping through or something when you
notice that so when you're putting a
condom on maybe maybe I can't do it okay
but I think that works just off the back
of what you've said I think I've just
clocked it that would prove it so so for
example if she kept the condom as
evidence and there was holes in the
condo in all honesty then maybe it was
just no there's no good can I finish
there no there's no good way to prove it
no there's no there's no goodness
you can prove it this is this is like
this is how in my opinion a lot of false
accusations come because there's no
really good way to prove this stuff
because well yeah but it's still going
to be he said she said no no you consent
no because if she's kept the condom if
she kept the condom and there's no holes
in it let me let me know how would they
know it was consensual or not oh let me
know I let you talk a lot all right but
I haven't landed though if the condom
has got no holes or no splits or nothing
in it and she's pregnant it would surely
show that the condom had to have been
physically removed if there was holes or
or gaps in a condom then maybe it was
actually but you still wouldn't know if
she consented to it being removed or not
no you wouldn't so exactly I'm only
going off that's my point so it goes
back if he said she said it's only two
people in a room unless there's cameras
correct correct correct
um so we're I'm kind of going to go into
what you were saying earlier do you guys
think that men should have an opinion on
abortion because we constantly hear my
body my choice men shouldn't have an
opinion on this
but today we have a doctor here who
probably knows more about abortion than
most people had imagined doctor
um so should should men have an opinion
on abortion I I think I think yes I
think yeah yeah for sure yeah 100 what
do you guys think it's half it's it's a
piece of you it's a piece of me like you
know what I mean what do you guys think
on the couch
um I actually think no
no I actually think that it's the
woman's Choice yeah
okay she said can you have an opinion
but it's the same thing like what I said
about women having the um the final say
if a guy still has a part saying having
sex and a guy should still have Parts
saying if they have an abortion or not a
guy has a part say whether you remove a
condom or not whether women feel like a
guy should have a say or not a guy has a
say because they're short it's your
organs we're all talking about um do you
think do you think a guy should be able
to veto an abortion so so let's say
let's say you got pregnant and you won
an abortion the father of the kid could
he have a say in it yeah like if the
father so if he said no and you wanted
it would you go with like do you think
he should be able to legally say you
can't have an abortion no but it's
that's that's where that's where some
people that's where you were talking
about accountability and responsibility
kind of comes from because if you're
gonna have unprotected sex with somebody
it kind of some people obviously if
you're not in a relationship you're not
in a relationship but you need to kind
of still choose who you're having sex
with wisely because you need to be able
to know the person you're having sex
with you can still have that kind of
conversation and come to an
understanding and stuff like that you
have to kind at the end of the day
there's only yay or nay you have to come
to an agreement so okay but so you would
you personally would take his opinion
into account yeah
legally you still think you should have
no say no I'm not saying legally he
shouldn't have no safety no I'm sorry
I'm asking like what what would it look
like so if he he gets to say what say
does he get if I it's all to do a pros
and cons really are we ready to have a
baby are you financially ready to have a
baby am I financially ready to have a
baby
so I'm saying two people yeah the woman
says I want an abortion he says that's
my kid I don't want you to have one
should he legally have any rights in the
situation I'm asking you
um
see there I don't know there you would
have actually I think legally I I
couldn't answer that I'd like to be fair
because okay but you think they guys
should or shouldn't no so sorry so I
think he should not have a say so it
should be that I am I know you don't
agree with it okay I do I do I do but I
do think it is the woman's Choice it is
the body of the woman and yeah I just I
think that is the way I think otherwise
you're just going to be going back and
forth on who say should it be
um and it's just you're never gonna get
it my thing is if we're gonna make it
equal why don't we actually make it
equal that's right why don't so why
don't men get to like sign off on child
support yeah personally personally in
Pearl's world it would all be banned but
my question is like why why don't the
pro-choice people give men an out
because we give women an out because for
the child well can I just say
um if if I do think that they should
have a say legally but the the the only
reason that I think that the only way
that you can is if you're gonna be
legally put in a stop to me
get in a bush getting an abortion okay
then legally you have to be involved 50
legally because if you stop me from
getting this abortion and I run off and
leave me with this baby
mate that's not okay yeah so if that
that is the only way I would see that it
would be okay Legally Legally yes okay
but if they have okay so you you
actually kind of want it to be equal in
a way yeah and you think he should be
able to sign off on child support okay
okay why did I say something yeah go
ahead I think
um just the the the the process process
of making a baby it's already an unequal
thing that woman has to carry a baby and
go through the go through the the nine
months ten months pregnancy and then you
know have the baby so my opinion man can
have uh men can persuade the woman or
say whatever based on the situation but
women decide
on the final yeah the final second okay
and you would not be for them being able
to sign off on child support
so if women have the final say which is
fine right but could men then say I
don't if you don't want to be a mother
then I don't have to be a father and if
you keep the baby when he doesn't want
it he can sign off on child support
uh personally as a modern woman I mean
if I chose to have the baby and he
doesn't want to I don't mind right sign
off sign off it you know I I would raise
the baby myself if I chose to okay yeah
okay I'm curious why don't you think men
should have an opinion on it
all right so my mom was a very proud
woman okay and she never received any
child support from her I didn't even
realize you said that I was asking her
oh I'm sorry do you want me to stop uh
it's okay um can I ask her and then I'll
ask you next go ahead uh can you why
don't you think men should have an
opinion on abortion
um because the woman's body changes so
much
um it's nine to ten months and of being
pregnant and after you have been
pregnant your body will never be the
same so first of all your body's change
forever that's one thing that I don't
think a man has the right to uh
challenge that really
um and the second thing is that
is like more of the broader discussion
of women's rights that like
statistically
um women has less rights than men what
rights don't we have I mean we earn less
I mean this because we don't do as hard
of jobs we do no we don't yes we do we
do did you build the building next door
go be a plumber go be an electrician
okay the power grids the oil rigs go so
this is this is a massive this is a
massive discussion and I'm more than
happy to start it but uh they're hiring
there's an oil rig I mean women has they
have they have been personal I mean
servants for men in homes for years and
years and years it is never a service
just men protected them oh just a second
so and abuse them as well yeah yeah I
mean they also died for women by going
to war and protecting us it wasn't for
women it was for their country no it was
for women women
it was for the government too but women
still got to live in that Society while
not defending it yeah but that's because
we've had this discussion before we've
spoken about men being physically
stronger so that's why they've gone into
fight
correct correct but you don't think we
should thank them that's a privilege no
we're not saying that but when the young
lady's talking about the body and and
then you know I'm saying I'll let you
continue thank you
um so basically it hasn't been the
woman's choice of not
becoming a doctor becoming a lawyer I
mean get it I mean inheriting property
that hasn't been the or I mean to not
have that right hasn't been the woman's
Choice up until like
um later in time so I feel like we're
kind of hanging
on the back are it a little bit and now
women are picking up they are becoming
Prime Ministers and they are you know
they are doctors and lawyers but it
takes time and I feel that I mean
statistically now in the world women has
less rights
well I would say that's not true I would
say we have more rights so like then you
can start to compare I mean thinking
about women in America how many women
are in office how many women women
becoming more equal like I think we're a
good chunk of Congress now
um I don't know what percent off the top
of my head but women don't want to do
the hardest jobs how do you know because
we don't there's no barriers stopping us
and we don't do them have you spoken to
these women yeah actually you'd be
surprised I probably talked to more
women in a lifetime than any of you yeah
people I mean women to listen to women
who say that they they interview I've
interviewed them in the trades we just
interviewed them last week that's what
I'm saying women do not apply for these
jobs women do not apply for the hardest
job women
I would say I would say the hardest jobs
oil rigs I would say Plumbing
electricity I would say building
buildings how about being in US isn't
that I would say that is I would say I
would say what's harder as a brain
surgeon which more men are
hmm I mean okay so a really interesting
thing is that I
um
I've learned that chefs there's more
male chefs
as a occupation than female chefs but in
the home it's usually the woman that
cooks right in my home in Love Actually
but
um but like
so when you
when you sort of come to a certain level
that there's more I don't know like
um
prestige in that job then then you know
it's immense but because men compete for
it I think that's our role that's our
role in the society like why man has
more what is it cholesterol the for the
muscle oh
to build muscles you know they're made
for doing these um building house or you
know they go out to hunt these kind of
jobs that's what they are made for and
women women are more caring yeah right
but it would it would make more sense
that they're paid more if they make up
the majority of workplace deaths so
they're doing the more dangerous hard
jobs I'd imagine there's a payout for
that women you don't think you don't
think they would pay more if you if
they're willing to die to do it yeah but
there's also there's also jobs out there
100 that
are the same job and yet one like a man
will be paid more and a woman will be
paid less yeah
I've worked in one if you want to know
what was the job well I was lifeguard
okay
um so um when you when you were applying
for the job did you apply for the job
like on the job board like indeed or
something like that no I had worked as a
lifeguard for three years and then I
switched working place and then I
learned the other person that had less
experience than me he was the man he
earned about three quid more
um anyway and did you when you ask when
you say lifeguard that's that's a very
nice
um example because I would think that
um
the point I'm trying to make anyways is
when you apply for any job role
is there do you see well like if you say
you want to become a lifeguard for
instance and you see it on indeed do you
see
um lifeguard role women salary 10 pounds
an hour men's salary 15 pounds an hour
or do you see lifeguard rule 10 pounds
an hour and whoever gets hired gets that
salary it usually says from depending on
experience or something like that well
okay then then that would come to
negotiation power that has nothing to do
with sex um one of my other question is
why don't we talk about the women models
get paid more than male models where is
everyone where is the marches
right someone causes the cost so the
reason why that women and it works the
other way around too so the reason why
women don't tend to be in male dominated
Industries as much is just because it's
unpleasant it's saying for the reason
why men don't women women don't want to
do hard jobs no okay do you think a
veterinarian is a hard job
I mean you can find some Niche like
primaries you can find some Niche Fringe
things
the number one employers of women is
it's teachers and nurses yes because
that's how it's always been and you're
right correct what is the hardest jobs
the ones that have the most workplace
deaths men do them so it makes sense
that they're paid you're defining hard
by simply are you more likely to die
which is about a dark way
okay you don't think a job is harder to
do if you might die doing it to be fair
you can die if you work in a hospital to
be fair you might catch up I mean you
can but it's it's not as likely as I as
that job to deal with animals they're
pretty unpredictable right what person
let's go into vets one percent of um
vets are women double okay
so it's 60 it's so it's still close to
15. no it's over 60 I said double so
it's like okay
I just was expecting because in the
industries I mentioned it's like 95 men
it's not close to 50 50. you don't think
you've got two-thirds I don't I don't
think that's the same as 95 I think men
have been working for a lot longer than
women I mean so I think women are still
trying to come into their fields you
know there's some women that are still
reliant on men some women are still
reliant on their parents even you know
there's women that are in their 20s and
they're still relying that's just an
excuse if you were born today you have
no barriers they're absolutely that's
fine but in regards to like trying to
move up and trying to get further in
your career not just getting to a career
entry level it can be difficult quotas
they literally pay companies to hire
women but do you realize the older
Generations haven't died yet so you're
going to need to give it a couple
Generations before we can actually judge
it I mean it's going to be more older
people that do that that's just such a
car back the older generation wants to
make money if you're telling me you you
tell a 55 year old dude you get money to
hire women you don't think he's gonna
hire more women now that's not what I
mean I mean until the older generation
have died where there is still
inequality because obviously if you're
going past 60 years old all those women
that are that old still have the same
mindset that they had because they
didn't have I mean from where from what
era like how old are you talking like my
like my mom the Equal Pay Gap the Equal
Pay Act was it was in 1964. I'm talking
about opportunities from going to
University so it's only been 1963 was
the equal it's been illegal it is
illegal to pay women less than men this
young lady's already given an example
that she's been underpaid and this was
before this was after the 60s
and it's still an example
other examples
and I have examples where I've got paid
more like than a guy could I could I
just ask what did you say you're a
doctor right yes
what is your stance on this and
especially in the hospital like because
obviously we talk about nurses and Etc
so I just wanted to know what you it's
it's difficult I mean you know clearly
the majority of doctors at the moment
are male that's mainly because of the
older Generations the majority of
medical students and young doctors are
female sort of switched around and that
part of that's part of the reason this
is so complicated is because we're often
measuring people of different
Generations so I honestly don't know I
think probably from anecdotes from my
own experience or my reading of the data
there are ways that women get screwed
over in the job market than men the men
don't there will be some the other way
around I don't know who is worse off
overall and it it's almost a red herring
because the question was does this mean
that men can't have an opinion on
abortion I just think yeah what do you
think of that do you think so so I think
you know there's so many things to say
about this one was I used to be a fetus
which I think is important one is I
might have my own kids one day you know
this feeds us some of the feeds this
might be mine hopefully not that many
because I only have one wife who's next
to me
um
what I really think is you know when we
think about Justice and when we think
about having a community that works
together in a society that functions we
have to have men and women talking to
each other giving their best to each
other
and working in harmony right so take an
example Emma Watson's campaign he for
she that was basically saying for
women's equality we cannot just do this
with women alone men have to use
whatever platform they might have we can
debate whether they have it whatever
privilege they might have men have to
use it to fight for equality now the way
I think that links to abortion is
firstly that I think the pro-life view
is about equality for the child as well
saying the child has an equal right to
life so everyone has a duty to fight for
that but at the same time what really
gets me about this is
think about before abortion was
legalized if a man gets a woman pregnant
the likelihood is they get married
suddenly some of those marriages don't
work out I admit but many of them do the
man provides for the child the man
provides for the woman and the man has
that sense of responsibility now what
happens when abortion is legal
the man can suddenly have sex with
whoever he wants and when she gets
pregnant he says it's your body it's
your choice and therefore it's your
responsibility and your burden
and so what is meant to be a burden
shared by the father and the mother
equally has become something that is
just on the mother now because the man
says this is a woman's issue this is
your body this is your choice so all of
those women who think okay now I'm
pregnant some of them will have an
abortion okay many of them don't want to
have an abortion even if it's not
planned even if it's not wanted many
other women don't want to have an
abortion because they disagree with it
because they don't want to go through
the trauma of it whatever reason
and now they're faced with a man who
says it's your body it's your choice
this is your issue I'm having nothing to
do with it that is why I think
portraying it as a woman's only issue is
harmful to women themselves because this
was a job that is for a man and a woman
to do together in Partnership why
wouldn't you want the like join like to
to be strong together and get through
things together even if you don't want
to be with that man
that man is still the reason you are in
this situation
exactly you have done it together it's
not his fault it's not your fault it's
together both of you have made that
decision both of you you should be
together through the decision and I
think if if a guy goes I don't want
anything to do with it
then it's a different situation but why
wouldn't you want to even just have that
kind of extra bit of strength that you
need to get through this level up on
that so so one of the kind of arguments
for abortion originally was it's going
to get rid of single motherhood because
we have all these women who you know get
pregnant the man has abandoned them they
can just have an abortion now but what
actually happened is that when abortion
was legalized single motherhood
skyrocketed because of this dynamic
because men still got women pregnant
they got more women pregnant and then
they just pissed off and so what you
actually saw was so many more women get
into single motherhood which has
economic costs it has relational costs
it has cost of your time your resources
any cost you can imagine we know how
difficult Parenthood is or many of us do
I don't know exactly because I'm not one
yet
um but Parenthood is difficult and what
happened when abortion was legalized was
that all the cost of Parenthood went on
to mothers because the man said this is
your issue and so I think abortion
actually has made things worse and
there's good evidence for this you know
the the poverty in the United States was
going to be eliminated before 1970 it
was on a downward trend for decades and
decades they were going to stop poverty
in America a Nobel prize-winning
Economist George akiloff wrote a paper
in an economic journal and he said since
1970 when abortion was legalized and
he's pro-choice he said since that time
the feminization of poverty has begun
more women have gone into poverty more
ethnic minorities have gone into poverty
more children have gone into poverty
because of this Dynamic and so you know
we can say that abortion is liberating
for women that it allows women to pursue
their careers and have more money the
reality is it's the poorest women who
have suffered from this because they
have been the ones who have had to
shoulder the burden of the absent men
and that was caused by abortion if you
know according to the statistics and and
you know you've made some really good
points and I think you sound like a
really good guy you know and that's
probably why you have you know this
opinion but you know not every not every
guys like you yeah not every guy has
that
um some guys will say yeah let's do this
let's do this I'll be with you and then
two three years down the line they're
gone
there's been terrible men and terrible
mothers yes
abandoned women since the Year Dot this
isn't a new thing yeah and I mean
everyone I don't really I think the myth
I think the deadbeat dad is a myth I
think it's more women that don't give
men access to their children I think
it's a mix I I no I don't know what
promotion but I think there's both right
like yeah I think there's way more women
that don't let men see their children
than vice versa that's my opinion why do
you think that Pearl can I ask
um it's just from interviewing guys like
I'm doing a documentary on divorce and
you would just be shocked by how many
men there are in this country that want
to see their children so bad so I
actually know something I will like cry
why don't they fight for Access
I'll tell you why it's because one phone
call a woman can ruin a man's life it
just takes one phone call so essentially
what a girl can do is if if I'm dating
someone right and we have a kid together
I can make one phone call accuse him of
um get a restraining order against him
with basically no evidence get him
arrested and then you are incentivized
to do that because you get a free lawyer
in divorce court
so now you go to divorce court and the
the crazy thing is especially when covet
happened it took a lot a lot of um the
cases that I've looked at took one to
two years to actually happen so in that
time period he doesn't have access to
his kids and then um he has to pay child
support in the time and the in the time
being a lot of the guys were kicked out
of their houses and every and he's known
by everyone as an abuser again this is
all with no evidence because in family
court it's not based on evidence it's
based on a balance of probabilities so
so it's not in Criminal Court this is
Family Court
um and so basically uh it's so sad it's
like literally the saddest thing these
guys will live like a mile from their
kids and they don't have access to them
they can't see them I know one guy that
went through Court to see his kid and he
lost so much weight he couldn't eat he
was depressed because his his uh misses
well he wasn't he wasn't married but his
girlfriend took the child away but I
know a lot of guys and that was just one
I know so much women that have got waste
man baby fathers and I think they both
exist but the ratio is nowhere near even
this is what I think I think there's two
things that go on one women do I make
bad reproductive choices in my opinion
where they they reproduce with a guy
that clearly is a bad pick toxic like
abusive control like whatever whatever
they'll say right
um but I I do think that the second
thing going on is we only hear the
woman's side and I think we have an
innate like proclivity to just believe
women when they tell us things and I
think a lot of times if you heard the
man's point of view like I know know
someone that like is literally
destroying like a man's reputation on
social media and the husband reached
like saying he's a deadbeat dad he left
all the stuff the husband reaches out
and says that she left with the kid and
she hasn't had access to him or he
hasn't had access now who who's right
who's wrong right we don't actually know
yeah but but I will tell you it is a lot
more common than people think that men
want to see their children and the women
will not give them access out of spite I
don't personally I'm not disagree with
you I know they exist I don't personally
know any women like that not disputing
they exist however I think the ratio is
not as as much I think the ratio is much
larger that women are trying to get help
from their baby fathers they're trying
to get financial help they're trying to
get emotional help physical help but
looking after the kids so that she can
have a little life of her own social
life you know before she's an old woman
with cats you know I mean she might want
to date it's okay for him to get a
girlfriend she can't get a next man you
know it's a lot of double standards you
know I think I think if that were true
then more women women would let men have
50 50 custody
no no it's not true it's again men only
get access 10 of the time do you realize
how small of a number that is 10 like
they're correct we can agree they're
shitty moms they're shitty dads but 10
who who
um
what the left will do is they'll say why
don't these men fight for custody so I'm
going to go back to that story one phone
call this woman calls the police the
whole Community thinks he's an abuser
okay now he's lost his reputation he's
lost his friends a lot of these men go
so crazy they lose their jobs now by the
time they get to court the court says
why haven't you been in the kid's life
for a year and a half and the woman
there's no consequence for keeping the
man from his kids that will be a
consequences when the kids grow up it's
when like you're right it's when the
kids grow older but they also don't talk
about parental alienation and I mean we
have examples of celebrities that this
happened in front of our eyes like think
of Kanye Kanye loved his mom comes to
find out his mom that he loved right he
was on her side had never had took him
out of I think it was Atlanta or like
some somewhere down south and took him
to Chicago without the father's consent
and I've interviewed guy after guy after
Guy where a lot of times the woman will
leave the state or leave the country and
he gets no say and so a lot of guys
don't fight because they see all their
friends getting screwed in divorce court
because and I've even talked to divorce
lawyers about this it's like when a man
when a woman has a kid that is not your
kid it's hers because if you go to court
and you want to spend so now he's been
paying child support for a year
sometimes a year and a half he goes to
court and now he has to pay lawyer fees
to maybe get the kid for a 10 chance are
you going to do that a lot of guys just
say screw it I have no say and the rest
of my life I access to my child is
dependent on how she feels because the
other thing is women can do the same
process he could win maybe get 50 50
custody which he probably won't she'll
still probably get primary custody
because she's been the primary caregiver
for the last year so she'll still
probably get it they don't ask why and
the crazy thing is
she can do it again
so like I'll talk to guys they got close
to 50 50 custody like maybe they'll get
three days a week or two days a week and
they're happy with that then she he does
something she doesn't like boom she
calls the cops again I even I have seen
text messages of the woman trying to get
the husband to hit her saying I wish he
would just hit me
and and they literally in court they
didn't care she still got primary
custody how crazy is that I'm telling
you this is so common like this is the
number one dm I do not get any more DMS
than about this documentary
so the way that men can be proactive in
this case is to seek legal
representation first which is it there
is a benefit to seeking food but I'll
tell you I'll tell you the problem is a
lot of guys don't see this coming
because the women they can go to their
doctor and start this process and they
can go to women's shelters there's like
nine women's shelters for every one
men's shelter there are not men's
shelters like that so women go to the
women's shelter and what they do there
is they give them a whole story to tell
them about
um the the father of their children and
this could you know this could just be
hearsay but I've heard this from so many
different guys where they go to the
women's shelter and they'll say okay
he's Nigerian you have to say this about
him he's Eastern European you have to
say this about them like a certain story
based on their culture
I've had multiple
no I don't even think it's sociopathic I
just think women have so much power in
this regard and I I think like okay we
we take female evil right what's female
evil it's spite like women can be very
manipulative and very spiteful what's
male evil aggression right like they
kill someone they get angry and so it's
like okay if we legally gave men guns
when they were at their angriest what
would they do they would kill more when
we legally give women the tools to
destroy a man's life they're going to do
it more because it's legal because they
can't and the women's shelters make this
all possible and when you follow the
money they all like the lawyers um the
number one the lawyers have no incentive
to even help the men because who's the
lawyer's number one client
mothers so if you win too many cases
you're not going to be recommended
that's the number one client from the
lawyer like all of the money it follow
like it's a whole system I feel like I
feel like it's all extremely sad very
very very sad and there's conversations
sad I mean even criminals can get a
supervised visitors
pretty bad can I just finish there is so
many kids that are suffering so many
that I'm seeing in my family
friends like it's sad like listen to
what we're talking about it's sad it's
to just bringing children into this
world
and the child and we're talking about
the fight between the mum and the dad
and it's crazy and then you've got these
children these poor children
who I'm thinking of like smaller friends
are struggling because he's manipulative
she's manipulative and you've got this
kid who is just a kid and just wants to
be a kid and doesn't want to have to go
through all of this crap
and I think it all comes down to
promiscuous promise like being if we was
taught right if we was taught right
because it's not right to sleep around
it's not right to to just be like Oh I'm
just gonna get an abortion it's not and
even if you are live pro-life pro-choice
you know even pro-choice you know it's
not right to be like let's get another
version let's get another abortion I'll
get another one it's not right these and
it is a life and I get that some people
don't believe that it is a life it's got
a heartbeat you go to a scan the amount
of women that I know that have been like
I'm pregnant how do they know like and
then they've gone on the phone up they
are they knew they got pregnant on this
certain day like it's it's something
spiritual it's something that we cannot
explain no science can explain it no
like how can we explain a life a woman
create in life we create life that is
the that is the most amazing thing in
the world like man and a woman get
together and they can't I think you're
what I think it's this is just it's
really sad I I totally agree with you I
think you bring bring brought out a very
important point it's responsibility you
know you mentioned that it's you it's
your response it's our responsibility to
uh give out the birth but it's also
think about this if you are now you're
homeless and you have you carry a baby
but you you can uh you mentalize
unstable and you can't even afford to
raise a baby think about you don't want
to raise it you know well my mom was in
that situation my mom gave up um she she
had a kid um she gave up a kid for
adoption when she was 17. and it's
actually really cool he grew up um I met
him when I was 22 for the first time
he's 31 he just got married he just had
his first son
so I mean a lot of times we act like if
you're in a bad situation there's no
light at the end of the tunnel there's
nothing you can do but you know adoption
is really a great option for people that
aren't in a situation to have children
it's not we act like there's no option
but a lot of people they just really
don't have options they can't they they
can't have a baby at that moment you
know right there's there's so many um
families that want a baby there's so
many families that are like waiting to
adopt that especially with all the
fruits because people are having kids
later and later they're all the
fertility issues and a lot of people I
know we always talk about the foster
care system but if you put a baby into
the foster care system they're most
likely going to be adopted the issue is
the parents that wait to do it because
like most people don't want to you know
adopt like a five seven ten year old
system is horrible but I'm saying
there's a lot of fat but there's a lot
of but there's a lot of groceries I
agree with you but that's why it's
important to give them up for adoption
when they when they're babies it's a lot
easier to find a family to adopt them
when they're babies because the issue is
a lot of like incompetent mothers try to
keep the kid and they just can't take
care of it then Social Services takes it
away and the problem is most um like
families they're not looking to adopt
like a five-year-old from like a
crackhead or something like you know
that comes with a lot of problems but if
you do that at Birth it's a lot easier
to find a family dude
I feel like I feel like
this generation
and it's like now the abortion is
becoming more I mean you couldn't even
talk about it years ago like people
would be like we wouldn't be sat here
talking about abortion and we think it's
right and we think it's wrong and we
won't be able to because it's it wasn't
I think it was so hush hush and shameful
um because morally it's wrong like
that's what we're told and the thing is
we're breeding
kids that are think about the future so
the future if we're all like this now
and there's problems and there's issues
and you know there's issues in the
family and things like that and there's
children this child is going through it
they're going to grow up with other
issues as well as what they've got from
their parents this is why and then it's
going to be more and more this is why I
think it's so important for women to
pick husbands get married and stay
married which you would because if
abortion wasn't imagine if abortion was
banned yeah I think women would would be
would take more care with picking their
products and that's and that's the
problem is I just think we we have we
live in a culture that promotes
promiscuity and I don't necessarily like
do what you want to do but the issue is
that when you act selfishly everybody
suffers and the kids suffer especially
because if you if you leave your husband
now now your kid's staying in a single
mother home or boyfriend or you don't
pick a good dad oh I agree with you you
know in regards to like women picking up
but guys but at the same time I have
seen many a case where girls think
they've picked a really good guy you
know I mean he's ticking all the boxes
but it's a facade it's a lie and he's
toxic but my question to them is what
and I just have a hard time believing
that the parents didn't say anything and
even if maybe they don't have the best
home life that their friends didn't say
anything in my experience the people
that are in toxic relationships have
everybody around them telling them
they're in a toxic relationship and they
don't listen it might not be toxic
that's the thing now it might not be any
abuse and things like that it just might
be a case where maybe the man just
doesn't care as much as he let on you
know and that's that's the thing you
know if he doesn't care that much then
there's certain things that he won't I
think that's an unrealistic expectation
like like because throughout life like
sometimes your husband's gonna care more
or care less like I just think you can't
make emotional decisions that affect the
whole family based on things that change
and feelings change love is an emotional
decision that's why people make poor
decisions when they are in love they
look past all of the terrible things and
it's a it's a it's a hormonal chemical
reaction that makes you crazy so that's
why people make poor decisions it's not
like they are rational in their thought
when they're like oh yeah I definitely
want to have a kid with this absolute
psycho regardless I mean we could say
the reasons for it but I mean this is
why historically the family would help
pick out the husband because we knew
like there's a reason there's a reason
like they kept women away from like the
guy like the dad would say like
threatened to shoot them basically
you've heard that right that phrase you
know the shotgun crap shotgun what like
there's a reason we had phrases like
that because women
um it just seems like when we're left to
our own devices like the last hundred
years we started moving out of the
apartment around 1920 before that women
lived with their families and then got
married and it just seems like the more
reproductive choice we have the worst
choices that we make so it doesn't seem
like we do a very good job which is why
it's important to have men that care
about you helping you I don't
necessarily think that people made
better decisions in the past I just
weren't able to leave those decisions
regardless because they just had no
choice
it was a stigma that's not true there
was a stigma there was a stigma against
divorce so what what evidence do you
have of that
um the the fact that women couldn't
leave no what evidence do you have that
they were just miserable because it's
just I'm not saying they were all
miserable and saying that they couldn't
really what percent do you think I'm not
going to put all random statistics out
of it no but I'm just trying to
understand because if you think 10 were
miserable that's very different than 80
not so what I would say is it would fill
the gap between the LA that's the
marriage Gap that there is now that is
in Decline so there was always going to
be more marriages in a point of time
where you didn't have other choices
right so I'm not saying that all of
those marriages in the past were unhappy
because I'm sure like my great my
grandparents and my great-grandparents
were together for the whole of their
life wait wait but that's the problem
right there right there you're making
marriage about happiness and it's not
about happiness it's about family and
Legacy and Duty
because modern women you want everything
so how like I want I want my I want a
intact family Duty I want I want and now
I want to be happy on
topic happiness no you cannot rely I
cannot I cannot stand when women will
blame men for them not being happy your
happiness is a choice your happiness is
your own emotions you can't blame other
people for your own emotions so
happiness is in a constant state right
anyone that's trying to be happy for the
whole of their lives is a [__] because
that's impossible you you have parts of
happiness but there's a difference
between someone
um that can't make you happy all the
time which I agree is impossible between
that and someone who actively makes you
miserable and quite sad and depressed or
anxious but they're still wrong you said
makes you makes you you cannot make me
feel anything you you cannot I think
horrible things
it will affect well one one if he's
doing a bunch of horrible thing it's
probably you probably didn't have your
your father vet him which he should and
and but number two I I think it's
putting a lot of responsibility on the
men for trying to make them in control
of your happiness but you just said
about the father vetting him so that's
putting a responsibility on a mind of
some sort to say to for your father I
think I think it would be wise I think
we would have better outcomes maybe some
if some people don't have their fathers
around and I and I agree with you but
why is that it's because women laughed
because women leave the majority of the
time 70 to 80 percent of the time I
promise you yeah Poe and I don't know
the statistics so don't ask me but I
promise you yeah women will not leave a
man that is treating them well I'm
telling you I disagree sex in them
loving them good but we're listening to
them
we have been talking this whole show
about how women reproduce with these bad
men
yeah because some men sell dreams so so
yeah and I've been guilty of that in my
early days what can I say you know I
have to I have to keep it real so about
her but like let's watch what women do
if we're reproducing with the bad men
that means we're picking them
I mean we you there's a reason we have
phrases nice guys finish last there's a
reason it's not there for no reason but
that's not all women I'm not saying it's
all women but it's a significant portion
enough that we have a phrase that
everybody knows yeah besides um the
reason why we're having a lot of
problems with marriage today is because
it's the same reason we're having a lot
of problems in other areas of society
this new age we try to redefine things
we try to change the meaning of words we
try to change the meaning of what things
stand for marriage was never about love
happiness or all of that crap marriage
was marriage was about survival
marriage was about bringing together two
families bringing together resources to
ensure the survival of your offsprings
that's what marriage is for so at the
Bedrock of marriage should lie Duty and
responsibility not love and happiness
but we have more than enough people on
the Earth
for for us sort of like not to chase
love that's not true
billion people
no but the the issue is right now we
have a below replacement right even if
you have so yeah even if you have 100
million people if you're not replacing
um the people that are dying as quickly
as you should then eventually that
Civilization is going to crash and it
has happened this is not something that
is what predicting to happen that we
don't know it has happened throughout
history can I ask you a question King
do you think it would be a massive
problem if there wasn't that many human
beings on a planet because in my opinion
I don't think we're more important than
a planet I think the planet is more
important than us as a species you can't
even make houses cheaper that would be
great the thing is if there weren't
enough human beings on Earth human
beings would would make
um repopulating the Earth more of a
priority than love and that's what
happened in the past that's why we're
here today
the reason why the battery is falling is
because we are all comfortable now we
all can be selfish we don't have to
worry the way more than three women have
had an abortion exactly but is it a bad
thing though is my question would it be
a bad thing if there was less human
beings on the planet because we said as
a 8.4 billion people right now why my
issue is all this stuff is playing God
like I I just don't think as humans we
have the right to play God
so you have the right to decide when
life begins you have the right whether
the child lives or dies like I just
think we get into all these policies
where you're literally playing God yeah
because I suppose you know if a man and
woman create a life if that's if is that
playing good in your in your eyes then
um no well there's a there's a huge
thing about population control right now
yeah which drives me Matt like
it's it's just
um that's like really trying to control
all of us and so that's why they're
pushing for things that will cause
a massive drop in the population the
government doesn't step in at some point
and there will be incentives for people
to have kids it will be inevitable or
when I ban divorce abortion well I find
that encouragement is usually more
successful for not having a dystopian
country then then you know encouraging
where because it makes people feel
oppressed and then they don't tend to
feel very happy well when this isn't
about feelings I like outcomes well
right now the incentives right now the
outcome is that we're giving women the
ability to feel free have an abortion
and and they're doing it they're doing
it generally humans respond better to
positives
you would agree then that child support
should be banned because we don't want
to give people positive reinforcement
for breaking well it's the women that
are having the kids so no we're the ones
well that is an incentive for them if
you take that away they'll be even less
no no I don't think so I think there
would be more intact families I think
when you pay women to leave well we're
just talking about more children at the
moment not necessarily more families no
I was talking about families the whole
time
families there's a difference yeah yeah
I think families are good so the the
thing with changes uh now we are a part
of a society that has changed
um
you can't really Force things to go
backwards otherwise you end up in a sort
of authoritarian state right you like
you have to get married you have to do
this you have to have kids there is no
other one you can you can you certainly
can yeah
I'm not saying very well I don't think
that's a fair comparison
divorce was legal like 50 years ago it
wasn't that long ago it's not even I
think it was the 90s so that's like what
30 years ago it wasn't even that long
ago which is absolutely right you can't
force
um things on human beings what would
happen is we would eventually kill
ourselves off that's what is going to
happen so you can't force us to go back
to the way things were what will happen
is naturally we will take ourselves back
to the bottom and reset I think the
problem is when you look at the policies
whether they're like negative policies
or positive incentives none of them have
worked like when you look at all of East
Asia all of Eastern Europe now Western
Europe not a single country has managed
to get back to replacement level
population fertility not a single
country all of them have gone below
every single country in Europe is not
having enough babies to sustain the
population but that doesn't mean it
works
but I think that way in Africa too
because I thought I thought the average
number of kids in Nigeria was like five
it's still pretty high in most of
sub-Saharan Africa but it's going down
everywhere even Iran even in India India
is like almost below replacement
um and the thing is I think it's because
you know Hungary pays you goodness knows
how much to have kids like you have
three kids you get a free people carrier
stuff like that you get you know if you
have enough kids in hungry I think it's
three or four you pay no income tax for
the rest of your life they have huge
incentives man this is crazy but they're
not really getting the birth rate back
up and the problem is not so much about
economic incentives it's fundamentally
what people think of being a parent
people in the modern world especially in
the west just don't think being a parent
is that valuable or fulfilling and I
think the key issue is that we need to
reframe Parenthood and re you know show
that it's not just a burden it's not
just our kid who's going to ruin your
life and stop you doing things
kids are valuable they're great we're
looking forward to having them like I
think that's the key issue is we have to
stop saying you know being a mother is
going to ruin your life we have to say
being a mother is an incredible thing
that you should be hugely proud of and
that you should be able to do alongside
everything else in your career in your
family and so on I think that's the key
question I think that starts with being
less critical of single women then
because it's better that they're having
kids at all right no actually women
respond really well to social pressure
so I actually think shame is a great
thing
I actually think we should bring it back
I think we can have a sort of hop and
propaganda so I think we should we
should propagandize women and take away
most of the Reproductive Rights I think
we should do the birth control get rid
of divorce get rid of we can't even have
birth control no I would ban that I know
the men are like I can't get behind you
will not Korea over here
I think birth control is bad for women
these women go on birth control for 10
years it makes us absolutely nuts then
we get off of birth control and we have
fertility and hormone issues it can be
bad it's like is this really a good
outcome for us
to have the kids and then we get on the
antidepressants it's just like a
wholesale
it is that birth control has been proven
to be I agreeable after all that was
infertile on my show from too many plan
B's yeah she literally could not have
children from Plan B right and this has
been pretty common as well and Helen
said that people don't want to be
parents and I think that's true of young
people but women generally want to have
kids in their life but they're now just
leaving it until they're in their 40s
and we all know that that has issues
um so encouraging women to have making
it like absolutely fine showing
influencers showing like you know
celebrities that are able to maintain a
career and also um maintain motherhood
at home and maintain sex successful
motherhood
um see I just don't think it's possible
I think there's always going to be
something you have to give because if
you're working who's watching the kids
and someone else but I think part of
that is because we need to do it
together male and female that's right
we've lost the Parenthood well we've
lost that expectation of the fact that
we will find someone get married have
babies together we'll support each other
like I don't know like when you're girls
when you're looking when you're young
and you're looking for someone to be
with find a guy who's going to support
yourself as you know flourishing in your
career and flourishing as a mother and
that's going to be a partnership for you
both yeah I just think that's not
realistic I think that's what feminism
tries to teach us that you can have
everything and I don't think you can and
I also think there's a whole group of
women that have had nannies and like
daycare raise their children and I think
there's a lot of negative effects from
that
um I I think the the message that I
personally would say I just disagree
with you slightly but I I would I would
say you you have to make your choice and
you can't have everything I think you
can have more than people often think
yeah you're a lot more than people often
think and I think of course we have to
be honest Parenthood both motherhood and
fatherhood involve sacrifice I plan on
sacrificing a lot when I have kids I'm
not going to be able to do all the
things I want to do but the point we
have to make is that yes it involves
sacrifice for both but it's so worth it
it's more than worth it because these
are kids they're gonna be way more
meaningful than anything I just wanna oh
sorry I just want to add a certain point
on the fertility statistics because
often it gets focused on all the women
are getting too too old but it's a 50 50
perfect slit split split a perfect
or fertility issues men if 50 women 50
when it comes to getting pregnant
nonetheless that 50 of women now are
reaching the age of 30 without having
children which is very different and if
you see the chart the fertility
fertility drops way more for women than
it does for men at older age but like
that's not even disputable yeah besides
if women have all the power then why is
it 50 50. because women have the power
in production if women choose to have
kids later their men can only have kids
later yeah
older is usually not as good
but there are there are stats to show
that older women who have younger
Partners tend to get pregnant easier my
mom was one of those which is why she
could always get pregnant I guess
younger sperm is beneficial well I mean
younger I was just looking at the chart
of this today it's not the same it drops
I mean men do have fertility issues too
but it drops off way more for women with
age this isn't even like arguable is
that then because women are always
picking older Partners I don't know why
that is I just know based on biology
that women are less fertile the older
they get at a much more rapid rate than
men well by how rapid do you mean
because I can actually men can still men
still sperm in like their 70s 70s
I'm going to send it to Ken I just I
just tweeted this today that's why
that's why I'm positive of this besides
if women starts getting younger Partners
who's going to raise the kids
because are you gonna is she gonna trap
the younger guy into becoming
responsible it depends when you're
saying younger it could just be a 31 or
two year old with a 40 year old woman
it's not specific yeah but we all know
that men reach their financial strike
from 35 upwards I'm just very curious
about something so they definitely
shouldn't be having children before that
point then
100.
it goes back to the same thing of women
wanting everything so they want to have
the young guy but they also want him to
be able to be responsible enough to take
care of the kid or they want to have the
old guy and they want him to be or they
want to have the richest man and they
want him to be faithful to them like
they just want everything
do you know any 82 year old women that
have had kids
I don't know what the oldest is is it
someone in our 70s I don't know no no
there's Al Pacino just fathered a child
at 82. yeah you know damn well no women
are doing that I well I don't know what
the oldest woman I don't even know what
you're arguing like you know that men do
not you know that women drop off
infertility issues
I didn't say all men but I said women
have it worse the older they get is that
I mean we have a doctor here am I am I
wrong so my only comment was it's a 50
when people are dealing with you know
infertility they're having to seek
options
because you've got a bear I'm asking how
many how many people were in that study
it was a pretty big study that I I like
I mean you could probably Google it for
fertility issues I don't have the
website to mine I have some of them
written down but not all of them usually
government websites that are holding
these statistics so fertility issues
you've got to bear in mind some men and
some women just were never fertile in
the first place right we're all assuming
that everyone's fertile all of the time
it's not the case some people are
fertile longer right
I'm saying that it's not the same for
men and for women it's not the same
at 35 a man can have a kid pretty easily
women is geriatric pregnancy my mom this
is this is okay I'm not talking about
you I'm talking about your mom I'm sorry
about 35 is if you're able to get
pregnant no no no no no but I'm saying
it's still geriatric pregnancy if you
hit 30 the numbers say if you're single
by 30 you're more likely to not have a
child than to have one as a woman but
we're already talking about
I I I I'm saying that it is not the same
for men and for women I don't know what
you're arguing I never said it was the
same I'm saying that okay okay okay
so so no I'm saying that you know that
the older we get we have more fertility
issues and so do men no I said I said we
have more than men the older we get yeah
that I agree with you yeah
that's because you're brainwasher myself
at a young age men are gonna have more
issues and but then that changes over
time so men's fertility is probably
lower to begin with but it drops off
more gradually whereas women you know if
you're right about this 50 50 split
would have more fertility at a younger
age but then it drops very rapidly after
age 35. if you put it on the screen I
just was looking at this today
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna show it to
you because I've heard so many bad
stories about people that have been
pregnant after like four women
but what I I don't know I'm not seeing
no stories on guys I've not seen any
stories about bad things happening with
guys can you show the screen King the
oldest okay I'm gonna show you this and
I just want you to accept it that's it I
just want you I just ah nothing nothing
I just want you to look at the charts
I just want to I just want you to look
at the chart I just want all right so
this is this is nothing to do anyway
wait wait wait wait wait wait I just
want you to say okay that's it that's it
so this is the this is the fertility
chart
and this is different statistics than
what I was talking about okay so can we
just this is what I was talking about so
you do you understand this yeah I was
never debating it in the first place
okay thank you thank you I'm curious so
you're a doctor did you like what's your
experience with have you ever like
worked with doctors that have done
abortions or what's your oh wow uh yeah
I actually have a friend who ran B pass
the largest abortion provider in the
country she was the CEO but she's a very
sincere honest woman who thinks she's
doing the right thing for women and so
you know
um yeah we have a good friendship and I
have plenty of colleagues who do
abortions I obviously disagree with them
you know in the Hippocratic Oath it's it
literally explicitly says I will not do
abortions it's been pretty pretty
integral to the medical profession for
centuries and centuries
um I did not know that yeah it's um most
people don't know actually someone said
did you not take an oath why are you
pro-life and the oath literally says you
can't do abortions
um it's pretty wild
um yeah for me you know this is this is
an issue that is both ethical but it's
also medical like when you look at the
outcomes women who have abortions for an
unwanted pregnancy this is women who
have an unwanted pregnancy if you have
an abortion you have a 30 increased risk
of anxiety a 70 increased risk of
suicide a 130 increased risk of alcohol
abuse and a 300 increased risk of drug
abuse and that's if you don't have one
if you if you haven't if you have one
yeah yeah compared to the same women
with the same previous psychiatric
issues the same socioeconomic stuff the
same unwanted pregnancy correlation
doesn't equal causation there could be a
number of variables for those reasons
but that's why they take into account
all of those things so they adjust for
socioeconomic status for previous
psychiatric history for domestic
violence for all sorts of things and
they find even when you keep those
constant the women who have abortions
have much worse mental health well and I
and I think it's just common sense to be
honest this is why sometimes I'm like
you don't even need to study to tell you
that like I know women that have had
abortions they're never happy after
the women that are keeping them are more
likely to be in happy relationships in
the first place if they have the support
they're going to have better but this is
like you it's always a cope it's always
there's somehow
it's like coping
women I've never had that argument when
when we're talking about
um
well we're talking about
um the pig up so you will never hear a
woman say well there are so many other
factors that could contribute to it but
it's funny how to say that for abortion
that was never my argument either
we're not talking about you well he was
pointing at me
though but I think it's funny because
it's so it's so funny it's just
something I notice with girls it's
always like they take the argument and
it's like they always use me but it's
not about you well here I was the one
saying it I'm not even talking I don't
know I'm not talking about you I'm
talking about in general
um
so you said you're you're I'm curious
can you tell me what happens during an
abortion
yeah it really depends on the kind of
abortion so there's two main kinds
there's medical which means using pills
or there's surgical so in a medical
abortion you take two pills the first
pill will you know deprive the baby of
oxygen and nutrients so that it
basically suffocates and then the second
poem isoprostol will eject the baby and
cause you know labor cause a miscarriage
at a very late stage because the baby
could be born alive like if you do this
at 22 weeks the baby might come out of
the womb alive you have to perform a
procedure called feticide which you can
guess what that means it's the killing
of a fetus and that's one of the reasons
for thinking this is a living thing
right they wouldn't call it feet aside
if it wasn't alive wait so they'll
they'll kill it after it comes out no no
so what they do is before they do the
abortion they will put a needle through
the mummy mother's tummy and they will
stick it into the baby's heart or
sometimes into the head and they will
pump in potassium chloride and that will
kill the baby now this has been banned
potassium chloride in capital punishment
so if you look at human rights groups
they say you cannot use this chemical in
capital punishment because it's inhumane
to kill rapists and murderers this way
but this is exactly the same chemical
they use to perform feticide in late
term abortions now those are a small
number but you know they still occur
there's still hundreds of them each year
in this country
surgical abortions are quite different
at an early stage you use a vacuum so
that basically vacuums the baby and
destroys the baby through the force of
the vacuum after about 12 13 14 weeks
the baby is too kind of big and tough to
be vacuumed and so you have to dismember
it so you basically just pull the limbs
off the baby bit by bit it's horrible to
think about horrible to say I don't like
saying it but it's just the reality it's
a dismemberment basically
um if the baby's head is too big to
remove from the womb they will have to
crush the head should bring it out so
it's it's pretty horrendous and if you
read academic papers where abortion
providers give their thoughts on it many
of them say actually this is terrible
many abortion providers say I'm only
going to do it up to 12 weeks because
after that it's just too horrible
um so it's it's something that you know
most abortions are in the first
trimester I'm not pretending that most
abortions of these horrible gruesome
late term things but just as an example
there are three thousand abortions in
this country after 20 weeks each year so
after 20 weeks five months when the
baby's pretty much viable
three thousand abortions take place by
those sorts of methods and so it's still
something that you know if three
thousand children were being killed by
that method in any other circumstance
we'd say that's way too many that's
three thousand too many
um yeah sorry that was very deep so what
happened in the first one you said
they're deprived of nutrients can I
challenge you on that because I've
looked up both of these drugs so you
spoke about my super personal but me for
Prestone is the the first one that's
more common it's an anti-protestogen yes
and it causes the cervix and uterine
vessels to dilate and then it causes a
contraction I don't see it anywhere
where it's like
doing what you're saying yeah so it has
a number of mechanisms so
um there's you know three or four or
five different ways that it acts but the
main thing that it does if you search
online it will say it breaks down the
uterine lining so it basically breaks
down the connection between the mother
and the baby and of course that
connection is what's providing the
oxygen and so on sometimes the baby does
survive it
um usually the baby is killed by the the
deprivation of oxygen if it does survive
then it would be the contractions of the
uterus that will you know squash it and
usually end its life yes so essentially
the drugs that would I mean some of
these drugs are still used for induction
of Labor and such and well one of them
is also used for stomach ulcers or
something
so I I I find it I I don't know I feel
like the way that you said it especially
for the first drug it it felt more
emotional especially since because
they're having these uh abortions so
early on
when you're saying depriving the baby of
oxygen is it breathing because
I think it's breathing is it no so it
gets oxygen through the umbilical cord
but no matter how you're getting oxygen
if you're deprived of it you will still
have the same physics yes but I think
using words like breathing invokes an
emotional response in all of us and
we're thinking oh it's this little thing
why do you say breathing you said
breathing I think you did you said the
problem
yeah you didn't I I said it deprives of
oxygen I didn't say it was breathing you
know the the oxygen is coming through
the umbilical cord
um and that is just how it works now I'm
not saying the baby is conscious from
the moment of conception I don't believe
that I'm not trying to pretend that from
the moment of conception the baby will
feel things and will always feel
something during an abortion but
certainly by the end of the first
trimester I think is extremely likely
and we don't know exactly when
Consciousness begins but it probably
does begin within the first trimester
and at that point if you deprive the
baby of oxygen it doesn't matter whether
you're you know covering its head or
just cutting the umbilical cord or
whatever
when your body is deprived of oxygen if
you are conscious then you know that
will
that will affect you and that is what
causes the the demise of the yes but I I
guess with the Consciousness argument it
doesn't bother me because babies don't
even get self-awareness to 15 odd months
and I don't advocate for throwing babies
into dumpsters so the Consciousness that
a thing this small has is relatively
Irrelevant in my opinion obviously not
to everyone else here so why didn't you
think it has self-awareness till 15
months because it doesn't pass the
mirror test until around then you can't
acknowledge that it exists in it but
that doesn't mean I think babies should
be thrown in dumpsters just because it
doesn't have self-awareness capabilities
yet it hasn't even reached stage one
doesn't mean that I don't think it is an
entity that is existing that should be
protected and has protection sure but I
think most neurologists and
psychologists would say the mirror test
is not a good test of self-awareness
well it doesn't pass any self-awareness
tests until around that age but again
but I don't think it's important because
I don't advocate for destruction of
babies when they're born so whether the
whether there is any like valuable
Consciousness there doesn't really
matter too much to me so you think if it
feels excruciating pain as like a
newborn baby that doesn't matter no I
don't think pain matters now
I sound like a sociopath now but it's a
pain is a very little of consequence to
me it's a when you're dead you won't
feel it I mean they used to think that
newborn babies don't feel pain so they
used to do surgery on newborn babies
because they said these newborn babies
can't feel pain they're not sufficiently
conscious and they're not sufficiently
self-aware and so they would just do
surgery on newborn babies without any
painkillers without any anesthesia but
they changed that a few decades ago
because there was a pretty unanimous
consensus within medical science that
newborn babies can feel pain even if
they can't pass the mirror test
yes but if well regardless of when they
feel pain
if they are not of any kind of valuable
Consciousness to me which I don't think
they gain until much older
it doesn't matter because it
it's just trying to put an emotional
response on a blob
it it is not an entity that is developed
enough for anything to be of any
importance the pain receptors
are just irrelevant to me it doesn't
know of its existence it doesn't know of
its pain so why does the pain matter if
it doesn't know of it um can I just say
if if you was in
um
I have Consciousness and self-awareness
I'm not a blob yes I've never heard of
anyone calling a blob but that that's
crazy to me crazy can I just ask you a
question let me just say if it was
proven that
um
that you what if they thought you
couldn't feel pain when they still do
that with a little female
when he was in a coma or something yeah
and they start doing poking you and
putting needles in you and doing things
and you woke up and was able to say what
the like hello I felt all that
but it doesn't matter but it doesn't
matter because she was unconscious I
have self-awareness and I would be able
to experience the pain it wouldn't just
be pain babies have been proven to you
know like babies that talk
before they like be younger they're
getting younger and younger and finding
out that babies can talk and do things
and memory is real memory is real so how
have you got no consciousness if you if
you are so can you remember being in the
womb that would be impressive if he was
not unconscious and someone beat you up
and you woke up and you had bruises all
over your body would you not be upset
about that if I was unconscious I
wouldn't be feeling anything yeah but it
doesn't matter whether you're
unconscious or not you still got
assaulted
I don't know what point you're trying to
get at I'm gonna push yourself that if
someone's unconscious or there's no
consciousness of of of uh of uh kind of
temporary and then I wake up so it's not
the same is it but the fact that you
still got beat up to get it it's not
it's not the fact that you're
unconscious you're talking about oh
because I'm unconscious it's fine it's
fine because so if a woman gets if a
woman gets and it's if a woman gets
great if grape happened to a woman but
she was unconscious it's fine because
she was unconscious but it's basically
what you're saying though if you would
listen you said 15 months
yeah but it's different but are you a
scientist what difference do you do you
no you've just Googled stuff and you're
finding stuff have you physically done
like uh anything and found things out
for yourself
no no no no how do you have you with a
newborn baby have you you found anything
out yourself
or are you just going off words of
people that you don't even know what are
you on about everything you are saying
everyone goes off everything other
people have wrote written or read or
said yeah what is your point but my
point is I don't take every Fin and go
it's a blob like that to me is that to
me you don't have to be that crude that
to me is like it's a blob come on if you
have Consciousness why haven't you have
you not got a soul are you soulless
this is why I love my story to start
with sometimes
that's crazy to me I'm like in the
middle but that everything you just said
that's offensive like like if you if it
was your baby imagine this if it was her
baby imagine someone assaulted that
newborn baby
um that means it's okay it's okay
it's okay it's all right my child got
assaulted because I said this and a
child is an existing entity okay well
you've just said it doesn't matter if
they're unconscious if they're
unconscious
you're interpreting things from what
I've said that I know well if it was
your child it would be different right I
don't make arguments from emotion which
is what you are doing but but if it was
yours yeah
if you're saying I'm unemotional and
sociopathic
you said you were associated I know I
sound that way you no but you said that
no no one else has said that so you're
putting that out there you are you
that's the energy you want you want
people to believe that you're
sociopathic and I don't know maybe it's
for attention maybe you're saying all
this Lobby stuff to get like a viral
that's just I don't know but that but
that is effed up I'm sorry that is next
level
soulless like come on if it was your
baby I know for a fact I would bet my
life on it you would think different if
it was your baby but you're talking
about all these different babies talking
about a hundred percent if you had a
baby it would be different I think that
what if you was upset about something
that happened to your child because they
was unconscious and then someone else
said I don't matter why don't you crying
for your child's unconscious get her
over it because you're being dumb and
conflating an actual child with a very
early I'm not being dumb you said that
if some if an entity or a child or it
doesn't matter if you women is
unconscious and it doesn't matter
because they're not feeling it and I
didn't say that well you said that you
want me to say what I said because
everyone's getting it I'll tell you
exactly what you said you said that a
child doesn't have self-awareness to a
certain age so that's why pain doesn't
matter
the reason why is I don't value
Consciousness is because a child doesn't
pass the mirror test till then that
doesn't mean I think the babies should
be thrown in dumpsters
yeah
it's like how do we all hear the same
thing
if they're an early pregnancy that has
never achieved a Consciousness that
matters they will not be able to
understand the pain they can't
understand the or understand or like
live in the pain of somewhere
just makes up words you can actually
rewind it because she said she said what
she said that but she also followed It
Up by saying a child
up to a certain age can't pass the
mirror test so the pain doesn't matter I
think we can actually you know it's like
I think I think even through Choice
people are gonna be like proper like
flabbergasted by what you just said even
pro-choice people and no no even
pro-choice people are going to be like
what did you just say did you just I
actually I'm so I am so like taken aback
by that like I feel like
a lot of things happen right you are
going to make many pro-choice people
pro-life by what you just said like
you're saying that they're using emotion
to to get people you just did the
opposite used
in you was like yeah
that was like that was that was so he
said no one's saying partners and and
and I I have no like like I'm actually I
don't know if you can see how shook I am
but yes I have nothing so that is excuse
me
dying attachment to an early pregnancy
you've got no emotional attachment to
yourself mate like you've got like
you literally you literally and you said
that babies don't feel pain so it
doesn't matter what happens to them I
said everyone should protect their child
from you
and we're friends and whatever and we
smile and we say hi and I'm not going to
be funny with y'all but I just want to
make it clear I don't advocate for her
like hurting actual babies that have
been born we know you said the pain
doesn't work you said pain when they are
this small no because they cannot
experience well you said no no you said
no you said 15 months very obviously you
said up to 15 months
being born 15 months being born
I don't understand
I don't understand when girls do this
it's like how are we supposed to know
what you meant we got listening to me no
no no because we did we listened to what
you said and that was what you said well
if you want me to explain it I can do
the reason why I don't care about
Consciousness is because there's no real
valuable self-awareness in a in a baby
but that doesn't mean I want babies to
be hurt I don't think babies should be
oh and I classify baby as a thing that
has been born that doesn't mean I don't
think they should be protected and
looked after because I want our
population to thrive if we just throw
babies in dumpsters and treat them like
[__] that's bad obviously that's a net
negative for society in general but when
we're talking about a blob which is what
I literally recorded
I think she's trying to say before it's
been born I think she's trying to that's
what she drives that what you're trying
to say no she said 15 don't you
know I'm just trying to understand
wait wait wait actually wait wait wait
wait you will not you guys will not talk
over my producer exactly negative for
the baby first before it's negative for
society so you you even skipped over
that part that show that that just
further complicates what you're saying
how can you just keep over the fact that
it's a net negative for the baby before
you jump to it's a net negative for
society
and that negative to a baby is negative
to a society
like words have meaning and when you
start calling a child a Blog yeah that's
crazy
makes up these words
like pregnancy
but so can I can I clarify then
um I understand what you're saying about
early pregnancy what about late
pregnancy because I understand that you
would still consider it fine to to end
the life of the child even a day before
it no
okay so 21 21.5 weeks that's yeah if it
can come out and live that's viable yeah
okay so even in that late stage of
pregnancy it's better for the woman to
to deliver the child that child have a
chance of life
I think if it's viable then yeah it's a
life because it's viability proves its
life okay
so at what point does it in your mind so
is it a blob at 21 weeks and and one day
rather than five days it's very
difficult I was talking about early
pregnancy specifically because when it
comes to termination the majority of
terminations are within that window yeah
okay that's why I say I don't believe
that the pain matters because I'm
talking about abortion specifically not
like actually babies but what do you
mean by a block because it still has a
beating heart it still has pretty much
all of its organs it still has brain
waves that are functioning it still has
pretty much everything that we have it's
just not all of those things are
necessarily true yeah
I just have to say it's so like I just
can't even imagine arguing with a doctor
about what's true
arguments from Authority well I mean I
mean you could say that it's just very
arrogant like oh yeah of course I am a
little bit arrogant but that's what
makes debate fun I can sit here and be
like
okay I just want to know okay what what
is it
what was not true that he said
um well when you're putting in sort of
brain weight it's giving an implication
that it's capable of thought okay but is
that untrue yes or no
brain waves don't matter if there's no
no no no no no no no no no no
no
but the brain actually controls so many
other things apart from central nervous
systems exactly so how can you say yeah
well if there's no thought then then the
brain waves are not there
that's
no that's not what I said I'm saying I I
don't consider it important for these
reasons
look if if if we could but you said what
I was saying was not true if we didn't
say it was irrelevant you said it was
untrue no I feel like the way that I
identified anything that was untrue well
I said it I just gave an example of why
I feel like it's not so much that it's
untrue it's that it's irrelevant
so so it was true that there were brain
waves arguably but some of these things
are very arguable no no no no no one of
these are because stop stop stop okay so
it was true thank you
um because you said I said what was
something untrue then you said something
and then we found out it's true no
that's not entirely existing that's the
literally what happened okay thank you
thank you okay
um so no I'm curious
when what is the the first term abortion
like
so that that's when you were saying
basically the baby gets starved of
nutrients and then it like falls out
because I've had a girl on the show
describe it and she said it was like
basically like fully formed she was like
surprised how developed it was when it
happened to her people often I mean it's
yeah it depends again there's two types
if it's surgical then it's going to be a
vacuum which just vacuums the baby apart
if it's medical then it's going to be
the two pills mithapristone which breaks
down the lining of the uterus so hence
depriving the baby of everything it
needs and then misoprostol which causes
contractions and causes the miscarriage
so
honestly what people see varies a lot
because there's always a lot of blood
and it is small
um the best way that I would say to
think about this is not necessarily to
look at the baby after it's been ejected
and had its life ended because it might
be covered in a lot of blood you might
not see it at all it obviously won't be
alive anymore so you won't see the signs
of Life what I would say is if you go to
videos of embryoscopy which is where you
can actually do videos of embryo or
fetus inside the womb while it's alive
and see what it looks like so if you go
to ehd.org It's called The Endowment for
human development ehd.org you look for
the videos of say like a six week old
embryo this is when most abortions take
place around six weeks after
fertilization which is eight weeks after
the last period you look at the video
there it's going to be a baby of
so a video of a baby with eyes with a
mouth that can move its arms and legs
that is breathing its heart is beating
sorry not breathing but it's you know
it's beginning to do breathing movements
at eight weeks and so on so yeah like I
say when you look at those videos of the
baby living at around that time in the
first trimester you can see that it's
you can call it a blob but you know in
the same way that any of us is a blob it
is a clearly a living human being that
has most of the functions that we do and
I think it's it's clearly something that
should be protected
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats for a
second they're all gonna hate me they
hate me what's going on this is gonna be
worse
um okay uh let me well well we'll see
um guys make sure you like the video
there's over a thousand of you in here
right now so make sure you hit the like
button I'd really like to get a thousand
likes before the end of the show
um also guys make sure you subscribe to
the channel that's the
um we want to get to 2 million before
the end of the year so make sure you hit
that subscribe button
um okay let's go okay um blessing proof
Blossom are you super chatting in the
back
um can we contribute to kick this woman
off bullet um if a pregnant woman gets
an accident caused by someone else in
the fetus baby unborn child is lost
should that uh person face manslaughter
charges 93 toe pie Pearl did you yet
state that felons have more babies than
the average Joe why can't women choose
good men that was uh they want a fairy
tale where they are saved um Glenn
Lawrence Al Pacino just fathered his
fourth kid in 82 um how many 82 year old
woman do you know still having kids
Daniel you'll if you're not ready to
become a parent you're not ready to have
sex 90 free-toe pie less people means
more control the government will demand
a pale woman is dumb for thinking the
government has any solutions beauty
without desertion is like a gold ring
and pig snout
um Glenn
um women don't like shame because it
holds them accountable enter black
dragon if we had more families more
functioning adults Glenn uh Lawrence if
baby deletion should be legal should we
be able to delete all the homeless
people too since babies and homeless
both can't provide for themselves 90
free-tailed pie I'm a woman's Choice Hof
you knew that women aborted kids of a
specific colors that's still okay please
explain as the pale also Pale Lady don't
be condescending um Glenn Lawrence her
argument is weak and based on her
opinion on a time in history that she
wasn't even around to experience and if
your dad doesn't pick your husband does
your dad even love you enter black
dragon she's absolutely right my
daughter has been kept from me for 10
years she's only grown up to resent me
not being in her life while she faced
trauma Doug MPA men make up half of the
workforce but make up 90 of workplace
deaths since 1995 the rate of workplace
deaths for women is slowly declined I'm
Doug mpa's 28 percent of Congress is
women Mannie Fresh um question for the
women how would you approach sex and
relationships
um if you were socially and lawfully
forced to stay with the first guy that
got you pregnant for Life Men full wed
taunt men control relationships women
control intimacy female can say my body
my choice but men should be able to say
my wallet my choice why do women get to
be deadbeat moms via orphanages but men
can't protect their wallets Chris
child support is not for the child I'm
child support is for the mom to fund her
lifestyle women like yellow dress cannot
be honest while discussing this nail
bunny murder is the unlawful killing of
a human being with malice few decide to
end a pregnancy with bad intentions
abortion is killing a human being
without malice men will only be
pro-choice when they have 17 kids
enter black dragon for any how pro-life
people claim to assign a fully grown
human qualities to a zygote um
embryo and fetus II something that is
not called a baby and does not have
guaranteed visit viability of survival
Doug MPA women you think you want to
have their own birth control pill um you
don't think about how bad it will be for
women if men controlled access to
marriage and access to whether or not
you got pregnant uh mad Ram um
conception to full-grown adulthood you
go through various stages of human
development not changing between
different species you aren't suddenly
human 21st at noon you always were human
Doug MPA Kelly is a demon a demon has a
risen sorry I'm full we taught it is a
double homicide when women is pregnant
so there you go by the law the U.S has
two lives I'm g New York cat please give
um the death a clear definition of the
human what does a human Define it
clearly zoro's lost Kelly expose
yourself last pod being a fake Ally to
the woke BS use their language custom
since delusion to gain money succeed and
not get canceled sass uh some something
um uh you ladies are The Gatekeepers to
intimacy um with great power comes great
responsibility most women that terminate
don't do it because a grape used as it's
being used as contraceptive um Lawrence
if Kelly and if amboshia
sorry emobia I'm sorry I don't know what
that's saying it's considered alive so
as a fetus um
I don't even know what that means what
is that it's like it's like a very tiny
organism
satin back to back to Mars it
DNA sequest isn't fetus has inherent
rights and if um stabbed it's considered
murder that is The Logical leaps um here
are exhausting Adam Sutton great victims
virtually never terminate pregnancy this
is a red hearing you cannot legislate
exceptions this is uh the flaw in modern
laws and marks are dissent into tyranny
Glenn Lawrence why do you need a tax
credit for having kid isn't your
responsibility to be a parent when
people think of their kids as tax
credits it's cringe I'm gonna refresh
you know it's funny I just watched a
video of the Amish and um I was watching
it right before the show and they were
so disgusted by the thought of like tax
credits for kids they're like then why
would you work like why would you give
it they were so mad they were getting
money in their bank account for having
children
um 90 free top High um please reread my
abortion question would abortion be
wrong if it if it is specific as an
ethnicity
um
yeah I think I think we are going to end
the show though so
um thank you guys all for coming
um why don't we go around any final
thoughts you guys have anything you
didn't you know get to talk about and
you can shout on any social media that
you guys have so starting here and then
go around
um
well obviously I came on this shows for
your choice I'm still prayer choice but
from actually listening to the opinions
of a qualified doctor and some of the
things that you said I really did not
know about so
a lot of people when they're very
headstrong about their opinions I like
I'm open to learning new things and I
did actually learn some things some
facts that I didn't know and I'll take
that in like when it comes to this kind
of conversation in the future so yeah
um my name's Milan like I said my
Instagram is m double underscore LTD
um yeah hi guys
yeah I do agree um I came as a pro
choice as well I've learned a lot of
things tonight definitely it's a very
very sensitive subject I just think it's
important to understand
everyone and where they're coming from
because everyone's situation is
different
and I feel like there's no place for
judgment we should just you know like
just listen to each other and definitely
try to put ourselves in the other
people's shoes try to understand what
they're coming from but again it's
something that I respect everyone's
Choice it's a very very sensitive
subject so it's good that we talked
about it tonight I feel like we should
definitely talk about this more and
um yeah my name is Claire I'm 31 and
my social media is CLA i-w-o-u I mostly
talk about music thing
so this is a a new thing for me tonight
but yeah we'll do dating next week oh
I'm more into this okay okay good
um
it's a pleasure to be here
I think it's real it's a really cool
podcast we discuss with some race some
issues and discuss the the issues maybe
we missed
and it and it's really nice to learn
some of the things that I haven't get
touched
um
so hopefully I'll be back here again uh
and please follow my brand Instagram
it's called Paradigm Shift official it's
a fashion brand high-end fashion brand
for both men and women give the follow
that's it thank you
foreign
okay
um
so I am from Norway and in Norway we
have um you can have an abortion until
12 weeks of pregnancy uh well here's 24
so I was quite shocked when I read that
um and so I
I agree with the Norwegian way
um of you know I had that opinion before
the podcast and I still have it that
it's you know I think that's I think
that 24 weeks is too long to wait
because I read that at 22 weeks if it is
born it can still survive
um
yeah
and also we sort of touched on the
subjects of you know women in the
workplace and
um also you know women's rights and I
think it's very important to take care
of that and sort of like not lose that
Focus
um yeah I'm Aurora in Austin on
Instagram and yeah cheers
me okay I will apologize if I sounded
condescending I just kind of sound like
that all of the time
but yeah it's probably going to bite me
in the ass that I've fought with another
doctor online they're gonna meme on me
for ages for that but
I would like to quickly explain my
thought processes
so everyone perceives life differently
right
and I see potential life
um as being something that may happen
and it's not a guarantee in life
um
just as a potential energy is removed if
you remove the force that is holding it
up in place if you remove the potential
a life is a fertilization plus time and
if you remove time from the equation
among other variables it will not come
into existence
um Schrodinger's cat is a way that I
look at pregnancy the fetus is both
alive and dead until the box is opened
um in this case the box would be the
woman
um Schrodinger's cat is an example in
particle physics
that's how we understand
um the universe that's it's a paradox
that exists where particles
um atoms behave as particles and as
waves
um and
I think that
the reason why I believe this is is
predominantly because nothing in life is
guaranteed
um when when we have the adage which is
do not count your uh
chickens before they have hatched that
is generally how I perceive pregnancy to
be and I appreciate you might be a
little bit cold
and unfeeling but I don't have an
emotional feeling towards a pregnancy in
of itself as a concept so I apologize if
I upset anyone and my name is Kelly
probably you don't look me up you will
not like me
I'm sorry
yeah well I I didn't expect well I I'm
very grateful I came in as one of very
few pro-lifers especially as a man to a
room full of pro-choice women and
actually I've been really grateful for
the sincerity and generosity that you've
given so thank you all of you
um for me the pro-life view is really
just about equality
it says that every human matters every
human has the same rights as anyone else
and then it just says what biology says
which is that a human life begins at
conception that's what I learned at
medical school that's why when I went to
medical school I changed from being
pro-choice to being pro-life
um I also think the pro-life view says
we don't have to keep pitting the mum
against the baby as if it's a battle
between them as if the pro-choice is
side with the mom and the pro-life aside
with the baby I think we have to just
say both matter infinitely both are
equally valuable we have to do
everything we can to promote both and to
support both
um there's been a lot of like discussion
tonight about who's at fault whether
it's men who are mainly or women who are
mainly at fault for me it almost doesn't
matter because I think
both lose out when it comes to abortion
I think men lose out I think children
lose out and I think women lose out more
than most and so my My Hope Is that we
can have a world where where all of them
flourish and I think we're better doing
that without abortion
um in terms of social media I'm
obviously way too old to have anything
like Instagram or Tick Tock but I am on
Twitter if any of you have heard of that
um it's on Dr Calla Miller
d-r-c-a-l-u-m only one Ln Callum Dr
Callum Miller on Twitter my blog is
callumsblog.com where it has answers to
loads of stuff about abortion with all
the scientific references and things as
well so please do Dr Callum why I'm
gonna follow you thank you Doctor how do
you what was the last part uh on Twitter
Dr Callum Miller oh Miller okay
I was like he's got some good facts
oh I found you okay go ahead and do your
final thoughts well I'm just really glad
we got to have such a nuanced
conversation because I think um
everybody here could see that abortion
is not an ideal I think that's something
that we kind of understood that it's not
great it's not a great situation for
anyone and so often in the the pro-life
pro-choice debate it can be a situation
where someone says on one side the woman
only matters and the baby doesn't matter
at all
and that's not right right I think most
of us agree that there to some extent uh
the pain the the
um sentience uh the human nature of the
child does matter on the other side some
people say the baby only matters and the
woman doesn't matter at all we don't
care about them and obviously that's
wrong too but I do think we can find a
solution where both lives do matter that
we do find a solution Society where we
support both and men have a great
opportunity to play a role in that and
we should encourage and support all
three members of that situation so
um yeah that's my my view summarized you
can find me on Twitter at Louis mclet
and I tweet a lot about abortion and
family stuff I'm also married to calm so
you see a lot of his content come from
my feed too and uh yeah look forward to
connecting next time
yeah thank you guys for coming this was
really fun panel
um all right guys
um thank you for watching make sure you
like the video on your way out and
subscribe to the channel a couple
announcements before we on the show
first we have a Google form guys sign up
for the Google form we're gonna do
events in London former show guests will
come we might even have some of the
people that have been like musicians
come and do like music type stuff uh
we're gonna do meetups in London so
um sign up if you want to be notified
when we do it there will be security so
no weird stuff yeah you guys see I have
a big security guard here
um also guys
um subscribe to the channel subscribe to
our two clips channels just probably
Clips Pearl daily like the video on your
way out and we'll talk to you next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
King rich is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's Village Ashley Jenny's
podcast it's your boy The Fresh Prince
of someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men now I'm
not saying you have to be submissive to
every old waste man walking around I'm
just saying that it would be femininity
would be in your nature breaking it is
to find somebody you're compatible with
that you'd like not just of your same
generation and that likes the same
things that you do going out having fun
then get out okay okay then then get out
then get out faster then get out I'm not
here to get canceled today most men want
a woman that has some degree of
femininity where they feel like they're
taking care of taking care of I'm ladies
I'm submissive and you'll be surprised
because I will say what I want to say
now and I'll say what I want to say with
my mind but my demeanor doesn't change
and I'm gonna look down on him because
at the end of the day whoever you're
with is a reflection of you what has
happened to society that has made the
normal man a waste man I would feel so
bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag
now he's foreign
[Music]